WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THIS MEETING TO ORDER.
TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL HEARING
WILL FOCUS ON THE SAFETY
BENEFITS SOME CONCERN.
AUTOMATED VEHICLES.
AUTOMATED VEHICLES HAVE BEEN A
DREAM OF ENGINEERS DATING BACK
TO THE NINETEEN THIRTIES.
GENERAL MOTORS INTRODUCED THE
IDEA WITH THEIR FOOD FUTURAMA A
DISPLAY AT THE NEW YORK CITY
WORLD FAIR.
FUTUROLA. DEPICTED A NATIONAL
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THAT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY SHUFFLE CORES TO
THEIR DESTINATIONS AND SHAPED
OUR NATIONAL HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
TRUE POTENTIAL FOR AUTOMATED
CARS HAS BEEN OUT OF REACH UNTIL
VERY RECENTLY.
LAST YEAR OVER OVER FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED IN THE
UNITED STATES DUE TO TRAFFIC
ACCIDENTS.
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND OF THOSE
DEATHS WERE CARS STRIKING
PEDESTRIANS.
FURTHER THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
BECAUSE MY TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS IS
EQUALLY GRAVE.
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES
OF THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIETAL
HARM AMOUNTS TO ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE BILLION.
IN A SINGLE YEAR.
HUMAN THEIR ACCOUNTS FOR OVER
NINETY PERCENT OF ALL VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS.
AUTOMATED VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE THOUSANDS.
OF LIVES YEARLY.
HOWEVER IT MUST BE SHOWN THAT
AUTOMATED VEHICLES ARE SAFER
THAN HUMAN DRIVER.
DESPITE THE HIGH NUMBERS OF
FIGHT FATALITIES HUMAN DRIVERS
HAVE SHOWN TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE
MILLIONS OF HOURS. ON AVERAGE.
BETWEEN FATAL ACCIDENTS.
AS THIS TECHNOLOGY IS DEVELOPED
IS IMPORTANT THAT AUTUMN THE
AUTOMAKERS AND TECH COMPANIES
PRIORITIZE.
SAFETY
OVER PROFITS.
THE PUBLIC REMAINS VERY
SKEPTICAL OF AUTOMATED VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY.
IF YOU RESEARCH A PEW RESEARCH
POLL FOUND THAT NEARLY SIXTY
PERCENT OF AMERICANS SAY THAT
WOULD NOT WANT TO RIDE IN THE
DRIVERLESS. VEHICLES.
SAFETY WAS THEIR MAIN CONCERN.
DRIVERLESS CARS WILL SOON BE
HITTING OUR ROADS.
IN APRIL DMV BEGAN ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS FOR DRIVERLESS
AUTOMATED VEHICLE TESTING.
MANY OF THE REGULATIONS THEY
HAVE DEVELOPED KEEP SAFETY IN
MIND
HOWEVER.
SEVERAL BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED THIS SESSION TO
EXEMPT PORTIONS OF THE STATE
FROM SOME OF THOSE REGULATIONS.
DEALING WITH SAFETY.
I URGE MEMBERS TO BE CAUTIOUS
WHEN INTRODUCING THESE BILLS.
EVERY ACCIDENT CAUSED BY AN
AUTOMATED VEHICLE ONLY INCREASED
PUBLIC SCHOOL
SKEPTICISM OF THE PRODUCT.
A FAILURE ON THE STATE'S BEHALF
TO ADDRESS SAFETY WILL ONLY
REDUCE
PUBLIC TRUST.
WELL CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN TO
SAFETY DRIVEN APPROACH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS ASKED
DAYS TO LEAVE SAFETY UP TO THEM.
DESPITE THIS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
ISSUED ANY REGULATIONS DEALING
WITH SAFETY.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL HAVE THREE
PANELS.
FIRST WE WILL GET. A GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE ON SAFETY.
WITH REPRESENTS FROM THE DMV CHP.
AND THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
STATE LEGISLATORS.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM GROUPS
DEDICATED TO THE SAFETY OF THESE
VEHICLES.
INCLUDING LABOR THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
I CONSUMER GROUPS.
WE WILL ALSO HEAR FROM THE
ELECTRONICFRONTIER FOUNDATION
ABOUT CYBERSECURITY
CONCERNS.
FINALLY WE'LL HEAR FROM SOME OF
THE OF THE DEVELOPERS OF
AUTOMATED OF VEHICLES INCLUDING
GENERAL MOTORS UBER AND WAYNE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT FROM THIS
HEARING THAT THE PUBLIC CAN GET
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ARE DOING AND SHOULD BE. DOING
TO ENSURE THAT THESE VEHICLES
ARE SAFE.
I WAS GONNA ASK MISTER FUNG TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS BUT HE'S NOT
HERE.
STONER.
SO I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE FIRST
PANEL TO COME FORWARD.
Y. YOU MAKE YOUR WAY HERE WILL
DO SOME QUICK HOUSEKEEPING.
I LIKE TO HAVE.
ALL OF YOU AVAILABLE FOR A
ROUNDTABLE DISCUSSION FONG A
BRIEF PRESENT YOUR PREFERRED
PRESENTATIONS.
AND STAFF OF YOUR MEMBERS ARE
COMING.
LET'S TRY TO HOLD OFF THEIR
QUESTIONS UNTIL WE GET THROUGH
THE PRESENTATIONS.
NOT FOR THE PUBLIC THERE WILL BE
AMPLE TIME TO HEAR FROM YOU
FOLLOWING THE PANEL DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE I SUSPECT MANY OF YOU
WILL WANT TO SPEAK AND I ASKED.
YOU TO MAKE YOUR COMMENTS
COMPLETE BUT SUCCINCT.
AND TO THE EXTENT YOU CAN HELP
US FOCUS ON THE SPECIFIC ITEMS
WE WILL BE DISCUSSING TODAY THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
WITH THAT.
LET'S BEGIN.
WAS ENTERED ISSUES OPENLY
REPRESENT.
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER OCT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY.
I AM BEN HARSH WITH THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATURES
WHERE I SERVED AS A SENIOR
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THIS POSITION I TRACK
TRANSPORTATION POLICY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND ITS POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON STATES.
AND CSL IS THE BIPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION SERVING THE
LEGISLATURE'S OF OUR NATION
STATES TERRITORIES AND
COMMONWEALTHS WE'VE TO OFFICES
OUR HEADQUARTERS IN DENVER
COLORADO. AND OUR STATE FEDERAL
DIVISION IN WASHINGTON DC WHERE
I'M LOCATED.
AND SEE ESTAS MISSION IS
THREEFOLD TO HELP IMPROVE THE
QUALITY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
STATE LEGISLATURES TO PROMOTE
POLICY INNOVATION AND
COMMUNICATION AMONG STATE
LEGISLATURES. AND TO ENSURE
STATE LEGISLATURES A STRONG
COHESIVE VOICE IN THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM.
AND LIKE TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES
TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON THE
MOST RECENT DEVELOPMENTS
REGARDING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION.
A LIMIT MY REMARKS.
HE COGNIZANT OF MY ALLOTTED TIME
BUT LOOK FORWARD QUESTIONS.
THE AUTOMOBILE IS ON THE CUSP OF
A TREE TECHNOLOGICAL
TRANSFORMATION WITH POTENTIAL TO
DELIVER IMMEASURABLE SAFETY
BENEFITS REVOLUTIONIZE PERSONAL
MOBILITY AND PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT BOOST ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
HOWEVER THIS TRANSITION TO A
FULLY AUTOMATED AND CONNECTED
VEHICLE FLEET WILL TAKE MANY
DECADES IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
DURING THIS INTERIM PERIOD A
FRAMEWORK BE ESTABLISHED THAT
BUILDS OFF THE GREAT SUCCESS OUR
COUNTRY HAS HAD. OVER THE LAST
HALF CENTURY IN MAKING MOTOR
VEHICLE TRANSPORTATION SAFER TO
ENSURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFITS.
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AS MOTOR VEHICLES THAT OPERATES
ON PUMP ON AS MOTOR VEHICLES
THAT OPERATE ON PUBLIC ROADS ARE
SUBJECT TO BOTH STATE FEDERAL
AND LOCAL REGULATIONS. AND ZSL
UNDERSTANDS THE NEED TO CLEAR.
A CLEARLY DEFINED STATE AND
FEDERAL AS WELL AS AVOID
UNNECESSARY FEDERAL PREEMPTION
AND BURDENSOME FEDERAL MANDATES.
I'D LIKE TO START WITH A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF RECENT ACTIONS BY
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION OR NHTSA
AS OUR FOR IT.
IN SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NHTSA RELEASED A
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT ENTITLED
AUTOMATED DRIVING SYSTEMS OR EDS
TO POINT OUT A VISION FOR SAFETY.
AS YOU CAN LIKELY TELL BY ITS
NAME.
THIS WAS THE AGENCIES SECOND
ITERATION OF ITS AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE GUIDANCE
THIS WAS THE FIRST WAS RELEASED
BY NETS UP UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
IN SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
VERSION TWO POINT OH CAN BEST BE
SUMMARIZED IN ONE WORD VOLUNTARY.
THROUGHOUT THE DOCUMENT NHTSA
HIGHLIGHTS THAT THAT IT INCLUDES
NO MANDATES OR REQUIREMENTS
THIS IS BEST EXEMPLIFIED BY THE
CLOSING PARAGRAPH OF ITS SCOPE
AND PURPOSE SECTION WHICH STATES.
THIS VOLUNTARY GUIDANCE PROVIDES
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SUGGESTIONS
FOR THE INDUSTRY'S CONSIDERATION
AND DISCUSSION THIS GUIDANCE IS
ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY WITH NO
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS OR
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM.
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF THIS
GUIDANCE IS TO SUPPORT INDUSTRY
AS IT DEVELOPS BEST PRACTICES IN
THE DESIGN DEVELOPMENT TESTING
AND DEPLOYMENT OF AUTOMATED
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
THIS THEME IS FURTHER AMPLIFIED
BY NHTSA'S INCLUSION OF A
VOLUNTARY SAFETY SELF ASSESSMENT
OR V. S. S. A. FOR ENTITIES
ENGAGED IN AUTOMATED DRIVING
SYSTEM TESTING AND DEPLOYMENT.
IN IT'S IS VIEW A V. SSA. WOULD
DEMONSTRATE TO THE PUBLIC THAT
ENTITIES ARE ONE CONSIDERING THE
SAFETY ASPECTS
OF ATS IS.
TO COMMUNICATING AND
COLLABORATING WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION THREE
ENCOURAGING BE SELF
ESTABLISHMENT OF INDUSTRY SAFETY
NORMS AND FOR BUILDING PUBLIC
TRUST ACCEPTANCE AND CONFIDENCE
THROUGH TRANSPARENT TESTING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF ATS IS.
HOWEVER ENTITIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A VOLUNTARY
SAFETY SELF ASSESSMENT NOR IS
pENTITIES TO DO SO WHICH NCSL
FEELS MAY MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE VEHICLES. ARE
AS SAFE AS CURRENT STANDARDS
REQUIRE TO DATE ONLY TWO
ENTITIES WAY MO AND GENERAL
MOTORS HAVE SUBMITTED PSSAS.
WELL THAT'S A HAS NOT YET
ENACTED ANY RULES OR
REQUIREMENTS SPECIFIC TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BE EXISTING
FEDERAL SAFETY STANDARDS FOR
PASSENGER MOTOR VEHICLES KNOWN
AS FEDERAL MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY
STANDARDS STILL APPLY.
IT IS THESE FMVSS THAT HAVE
HELPED TO DEFINE THE DUAL ROLE
THAT FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLAY IN INSURING
ROADWAY SAFETY.
WITH NETS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING SAFETY OF THE VEHICLE
ITSELF AND STATES AND LOCALITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THE
SAFE OPERATION OF THAT VEHICLE
ON PUBLIC ROADWAYS.
HOWEVER THE MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY
ACT NINETEEN SIXTY SIX.
ESTABLISH THE AUTHORITY OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SET
FEDERAL MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY
STANDARDS AND THE CORRESPONDING
PREEMPTION OF STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ONLY LIMITS IS
PREEMPTION TO THOSE AREAS
COVERED BY EXISTING FEDERAL
MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY STANDARD.
THE COMBINATION OF THIS LEGAL
DYNAMIC AND THE LACK OF ANY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES SPECIFIC
FEDERAL SAFETY STANDARDS HAS
CREATED A SITUATION WHERE STATES
OF ACTED TO ENSURE THAT EARLY
STATE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. BEING
TESTED ON THEIR PUBLIC ROADWAYS
ARE IN FACT SAFE.
UNSURPRISINGLY THE AUTOMOBILE
INDUSTRY HAS RESPONDED TO THE
POTENTIAL FOR VARIANCES IN
SAFETY STANDARDS WITH A CALL TO
CONGRESS TO ESTABLISH AN INTERIM
FRAMEWORK FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF
SELF DRIVING TECHNOLOGY BEFORE
IS MATURE ENOUGH TO ENABLE
SPECIFIC NEW FEDERAL SAFETY
STANDARDS.
THE START OF THE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
CONGRESS THE HOUSE ENERGY AND
COMMERCE BEGAN ITS ATTEMPT TO
ESTABLISH AN INTERIM FEDERAL
FRAMEWORK WITH THE SAFELY
ENSURING LIVES FUTURE DEPLOYMENT
AND RESEARCH IN VEHICLE
EVOLUTION. OR THE SELF DRIVE ACT.
THE COMMITTEE APPROVED THE BILL
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FOLLOWED BY APPROVAL BY THE FULL
U. S. HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
THE BILL AIMS TO ESTABLISH THIS
INTERIM FRAMEWORK BY FIRST
IDENTIFYING THE PRIMARY STATE
AND FEDERAL ROLES AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE REGULATION.
REQUIRING THE DEVELOPMENT BY DOT
OF A SAFETY ASSURANCE
CERTIFICATION FOR THOSE ENTITIES
OPERATING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ON
PUBLIC ROADWAYS.
FORMULATING A PLAN THAT BEGINS
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING NEW
FEDERAL MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
PROVIDING DEAR TV AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE MOTOR VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS EXEMPTIONS FROM
SPECIFIC EXISTING SAFETY
STANDARDS AND FIVE REQUIRING THE
CREATION OF SEPARATE
CYBERSECURITY AND PRIVACY PLANS
BY THOSE ENTITIES SEEKING TO
INTRODUCE AND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
FOR COMMERCIAL SALE.
NCSL AND MANY OTHER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS EPRESENTING STATE
OFFICIALS INCLUDING THE NATIONAL
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF MOTOR
VEHICLE ADMINISTRATORS.
THE GOVERNORS HIGHWAY SAFETY
ASSOCIATION AND THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF STATE HIGHWAY AND
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
PUBLICLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE OPPOSITION IS BASED ON
UNCLEAR DELINEATION OF STATE AND
FEDERAL ROLES AND REGULATING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND OUR
BELIEF THAT THE SAFETY ASSURANCE
CERTIFICATION REQUIRED PRIOR TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF FEDERAL
SAFETY STANDARDS WOULD NOT IN
FACT PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
SAFETY ASSURANCES.
SOME WHAT SIMULTANEOUSLY OVER
THE COURSE OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE SENATE COMMERCE
SCIENCE AND TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION DEVELOPED THE AMERICAN
VISION FOR SAFER TRANSPORTATION
THROUGH ADVANCEMENT OF
REVOLUTIONARY TECHNOLOGIES OR A.
B. START ACT.
WELL THE GOALS OF THE BILL ARE
SIMILAR TO THAT OF SELF DRIVE
ACT.
AB START INCLUDE SLIGHT
DIFFERENCES FIRST TO IDENTIFY
THE PRIMARY STATE AND FEDERAL
ROLES AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
REGULATION BUT LIMITS THE AREAS
UNDER FEDERAL CONTROL.
REQUIRED THE SUBMISSION OF THE
SAFETY EVALUATION REPORT FOR
THOSE ENTITIES OPERATING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ON PUBLIC
ROADWAYS.
DEVELOP AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THE CURRENT FEDERAL MOTOR
VEHICLE SAFETY STANDARDS PERTAIN
TO HUMAN OPERATORS AND ESTABLISH
A TIME. FOR NHTSA TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING NEW
FEDERAL SAFETY STANDARDS FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
PROVIDE DOT WITH NEW AND
EXPANDED AUTHORITY TO ISSUE
MOTOR VEHICLE MANUFACTURER
EXEMPTIONS FROM SPECIFIC
EXISTING SAFETY STANDARDS.
AND TO CREATE A HIGHLY AUTOMATED
VEHICLES ADVISORY COMMITTEE WITH
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO U. S. DEITY
SECRETARY.
FOLLOWING STEPS FOLLOWING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE
NCSL ALONG WITH MANY OF THE SAME
STATE ORGANIZATIONS REFERENCE
EARLIER. FELT THAT THE AB START
AX APPROACH APPROPRIATELY
CONTINUES THE EXISTING LIMITED
FEDERAL PREEMPTION OF MOTOR
VEHICLES BY RESTRICTING THE
AREAS OF FEDERAL PREEMPTION TO
THE SUBJECT MATTERS SPECIFICALLY
CONTAINED IN A SAFETY EVALUATION
REPORT. THERE FOR THEREBY
PRESERVING THE HISTORICAL
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP WITH STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE AB START ACT.
PASSED THE COMMITTEE IN OCTOBER
ALTHOUGH THE FULL SENATE HAS YET
TO TAKE IT ON THE FLOOR.
WHILE THE REASONS FOR THIS ARE
EVER CHANGING I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DID NOT NOTE THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT BOTH UNITED
STATES SENATORS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH A FEW
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
ARE CURRENTLY WITHHOLDING THEIR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PENDING
ADDITIONAL CHANGES.
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE
THESE CONCERNS INCLUDE BUT MAY
NOT BE LIMITED TO. ESTABLISHING
A SUNSET PERIOD FOR THE BILL IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PREEMPTION AND SAFETY FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED IS AN INTERIM
FRAMEWORK.
PACIFIC LEE STATING THAT THE
PREEMPTION CLAUSE DO NOT
INTERFERE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
TRAFFIC LOS.
FURTHER REFINING THE NEW EXEMPTS
THE EXEMPTION PROCESS.
ESTABLISHING A SCHEDULE FOR THE
FORMAL DEVELOPMENT OF
CYBERSECURITY AND PRIVACY
SAFEGUARDS. AND EXPANDING THE
APPLICABILITY OF THEIR SAFETY
EVALUATION REPORT TO ALL
AUTOMATED VEHICLES NOT JUST
HIGHLY AUTOMATED VEHICLES.
IT REMAINS UNCLEAR IF THE
SENATE'S BILL SPONSORS AND THOSE
MEMBERS WITH THE ABOVE CONCERNS
WILL BE ABLE TO RECONCILE.
AND ADVANCE THE BILL TO THE
FLOOR.
FURTHERMORE SHOULD THE SENATE BE
ABLE TO PASS THE AB START ACT IT
WOULD THEN HAVE TO BE RECONCILED
WITH THE HOUSE BILL.
HOWEVER I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
ANY BILL WILL LIKELY HAVE MUCH
MORE IN COMMON WITH THE SENATE
A. B. START ACT.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS.
I THINK YOU WILL DO LITTLE ROUND
ROBIN AFTER EVERYBODY'S.
JEAN MICHEL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIRMAN
FRAZIER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE I'M
JUNE CHIMO THE DIRECTOR THAT
PART MOTOR VEHICLES WITH ME
TODAY. IS BERNARD STORY ON WHO'S
IN CHARGE OF THE THOMAS VEHICLE
PROGRAM FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRIEF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
REGARDED THOMAS VEHICLES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF VEHICLES BEGAN
WORKING ON A TOSS VEHICLES. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AFTER THE
PATCHES OF SENATE BILL TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT THAT LEGISLATION
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
REGULATIONS ALLOW YOU TOSS
VEHICLES. TO BE TESTED IN
OPERATE ON CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
ROADS.
COMPANIES WERE DEVELOPED THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND NEED TO TEST
THEIR VEHICLES ON PUBLIC
ROADWAYS GIVEN THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENSURING
SAFETY OF THE VOTING PUBLIC. WE
HAD TO STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
ENCOURAGING INNOVATION AND
ADDRESSING PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF AYE THE TASK
INTO DISTINCT PARTS THE FIRST
PIECE WAS THE MANUFACTURES
ESTING REGULATIONS WHICH
DEPARTMENT COMPLETED IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FOURTEEN.
IN DEVELOPING THE REGULATIONS WE
WORK OF THEIR PART AGENCIES
NAMELY THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL CALTRANS THE OFFICE OF
TRAFFIC SAFETY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH WE DEPART INSURANCE. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPECIFICALLY THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION NHTSA.
THOSE REGULATIONS CREATED A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE SAFE TESTING A
TIMES VEHICLES ON PUBLIC ROADS
WITH THE TEST DRIVER BEHIND THE
WHEEL.
THIS IS DONE THROUGH SEVERAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT COMPANIES NEED
TO MEET INCLUDING HAVING TESTED
THE VEHICLE IN CONTROLLED
CONDITIONS PRIVATE TESTING ON
PUBLIC ROADS. HAVING YOU TRAIN
SAFETY DRIVER IN THE VEHICLE.
REPORT YEARLY MILES DRIVEN ON
PUBLIC ROADS AND THE NUMBER OF
TIMES AND REASONS FOR WHICH A
TOSS DRIVE TO TECHNOLOGY WAS
DISENGAGED. REPORT ALL CRASHES
WITHIN TEN DAYS OF THEIR
CURRENTS AND IF ANNOUNCER SPOTS
ABILITY REQUIREMENT OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FIFTY TWO
COMPANIES APPROVED A TESTER TAAS
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
ROADS THESE COMPANIES INCLUDE
TRADITIONAL AUTOMAKERS EDGES GM
FORD NISSAN AND BMW. NEW
AUTOMAKERS SUCH AS TEST LENDS
UC'S AUTOMOTIVE SUPPLIER
COMPANIES SUCH AS BOSTON
CONTINENTAL.
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES JUST WAY
MARK WELCOME NVIDIA.
MULTINATIONAL CONGLOMERATES SUCH
AS SAMPSON AND SMALL START UP
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY.
COMPANIES OF ALL SIZES AND
DISCIPLINES ARE IT'S IN
DEVELOPMENT TIMES VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY. AND THEY'RE DOING
THAT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NEXT STEP AND BE DMV'S
PROCESS WILL DEVELOP REGULATIONS
FOR TESTING AND DEPLOYMENT
COMPLETE DRIVERLESS VEHICLES.
THIS MEANS VEHICLES THAT DO NOT
NEED A HUMAN IN THE VEHICLE TO
BE READY TO TAKE OVER CONTROL.
AS WITH THE RESULT AS A
REGULATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
EMPLOYEES REGULATIONS WITH
SAFETY AND MINE. AS PART OF THIS
FOCUS ON SAFETY THE REGULATIONS
RECOGNIZE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SETTING AND
ENFORCING COMPLIANCE WITH SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR MOTOR VEHICLES.
THE REGULATIONS REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS TO CERTIFY THEIR
VEHICLES MEET FEDERAL MOTOR
VEHICLE SAFETY STANDARDS A
PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF AN APPROVED
EXEMPTION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUCH AS NOT HAVING A
STEEL WHEEL OR BRAKE PEDAL.
IN ADDITION IN THEIR APPLICATION
FOR A DRIVERLESS TESTING PERMIT
MANUFACTURES MUST CERTIFY THAT
THOMASVILLE HAS BEEN TESTED
UNDER CONTROLLED CONDITIONS
THAT'S TO SIMULATE.
THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE TIMES
BILL WILL BE DEPLOYED IN OPERATE
SAFELY. THAT THOMAS VEHICLE
POSSESSES A TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION LINK WITH THE
REMOTE OPERATOR. THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS TO DISPLAY A COMMUNICATE
VEHICLE OWNER OR OPERATOR
INFORMATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. THAT REMOTE OPERATORS
HAVE COMPLETED SUFFICIENT
TRAINING TO SAFELY EXECUTE
DUTIES AND PROPER POSSESS A
PROPER CLASS OF LICENSE WITH A
VEHICLE BEING OPERATED. AND THAT
THE PASSENGERS THAT ARE NOT
EMPLOYEES OR CONTRACTORS THE
MANUFACTURES WILL BE NOTIFIED OF
WHAT PERSONAL INFORMATION IF ANY.
MAY BE COLLECTED AND HOW THE
NEWS.
MANY FACTORS MUST ALSO PROVIDE
THE DEPARTMENT WITH EVIDENCE OF
FIVE MEN DOLLARS INSURANCE A
COPY OF THE WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
TO LOCAL AUTHORITIES. DESCRIBING
THE TESTING PROGRAM AND A COPY
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION
INTERACTION PLAN.
BEYOND THIS AN APPLICATION FOR A
PERMIT TO DEPLOY REQUIRES THAT
THE TIMES TO BE DESIGNED TO BE
CAPABLE OPERATE. IN A TOSS LOW
IN IN AREAS OUTSIDE DISCLOSE
OPERATING ENVIRONMENT.
TAUZIAT TECHNOLOGY DESIGNED TO
DETECT AND RESPOND TO ROADWAY
SITUATIONS AND COMPLIES WITH ALL
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
VEHICLE CODE.
WHEN NECESSARY UPDATES TO THOMAS
TECHNOLOGY I MAY AT LEAST ANDREA
BY THE FACT TO DATE OF ANY
CHANGES. IN THE CALIFORNIA
VEHICLE CODE AND LOCAL
REGULATION.
THE TIMES VEHICLE LET'S MEET
CURRENT INDUSTRY STANDARDS TO
HELP DEFEND AGAINST DETECT AND
RESPOND TO CYBER ATTACKS.
UNAUTHORIZED INTRUSIONS ARE
FALSE FEEL CONCURRENT CONTROL
COMMANDS.
ANY IDENTIFIED STATE REALLY A
DEFECT OF TOM'S TECHNOLOGY THAT
CREATES AN UNREASONABLE RISK TO
SAFETY WILL BE SIMILAR TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE MANUFACTURE OF LESS
PROVIDED DESCRIPTION HOW THE
VEHICLE DESIGNED TO REACT WHEN
IT'S OUTSIDE IT'S OPERATING
ENVIRONMENT. RECOUNTED THE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH IT IS UNABLE
TO OPERATE RELIABLY IN A THOMAS
MODE.
A CONSUMER AND USE IT EDUCATION
PLAN A DESCRIPTION OF HOW TIMES
VEHICLES SAFELY COME TO A
COMPLETE STOP WHEN THERE IS AN A
THOMAS TECHNOLOGY FAILURE.
THESE REGULATIONS BECAME
EFFECTIVE ON APRIL FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. COMPANIES NOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TEST EMPLOYED OF FULLY
THOMAS VEHICLES ON CALPERS
POLLUTE ROAD RACE AFTER
RECEIVING A PERMIT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S AT THE
STEREOTYPICAL YOU'D ADVANCEMENT
PRETTY ALL THE AUTOMAKERS HAVE A
PRESENCE IN SILICON VALLEY.
WITH THE STATE'S OFFER TELL
ECONOMIC STRENGTH THOMAS
VEHICLES ARE BEING DEVELOPED
HERE AND WILL BE DEPLOYED HERE.
DOES VEHICLES HOLD THE PROMISE
OF THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
THAT IS SAFE AND PROVIDES MOBILE
MOBILITY CALIFORNIANS.
ALSO HAS THESE VEHICLES MAKE
THEIR WAY INTO OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WE NEED TO
BE PREPARED FOR WORLD WHERE
TRADITIONAL VEHICLES. AND TOSS
VEHICLE SHARE THE ROAD. BUT
BEFORE THIS BECOMES A REALITY
THE PUBLIC MUST BE ACCEPTING THE
PUBLIC OPINION FOR SUCH A
MIXTURE OF ENTHUSIASM AND
SKEPTICISM REGARDING THESE
VEHICLES.
DRIVERS NEED TO BE EDUCATE ABOUT
THE CAPABILITIES AND LIMITATIONS
OF A TOSS VEHICLES.
COMPANIES NEED TO DEVELOP
VEHICLES THAT DELIVER ON THE
PROMISE THIS TECHNOLOGY BRINGS
AND GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO ENABLE
THE TECHNOLOGY FLORES WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS.
ALL THIS NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AS MOVE FORWARD WHERE
TRADITIONAL VEHICLES AND
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES MUST COEXIST.
WHILE DAVID'S REGULATION PROVIDE
A PATH FOR THE TESTING
DEPLOYMENT BATONS VEHICLES WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THOMAS VEHICLES
ALSO SPUR. A BRIAR POLICY
DISCUSSION ON TOPICS OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT SAFETY FOCUS THESE
QUESTIONS AND MANY MORE WILL BE
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED BY OTHER
PUBLIC AGENCIES INDUSTRY
ACADEMIA. INTERESTED PARTIES AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
THOMASVILLE TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES
TO ADVANCE.
COLLECTIVELY WE CAN FOSTER THIS
A TECHNOLOGIST CONTINUES TO
DEVELOP IN CALIFORNIA IN A SAFE
AND RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
IS TRULY EXCITING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT INVOLVED IN BECAUSE
YOU COULD GET VEHICLES AS WILK
TRANSFER SOCIETY.
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE INTERESTS AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THINK YOU WOULDN'T OF FINNISH
AUTHOR WOODMAN ORDER YOU.
PREPARED OF.
ARTISTS BERNARD SORIANO FROM THE
DMV ACTING JEAN SAID IT ALSO
WILL MOVE ON TO THE CHP. OKAY.
SYSTEM CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR YIELDING A TIME TO
CGPA APPRECIATE THAT A. GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RICH
HAS BEEN ON THE.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL'S
LEGISLATIVE LACE ON A FIRST ONE
APOLOGIZE I COMMISSIONER STANLEY
WAS NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT TODAY
YOU WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
BEEN HERE WITH A. MEMORIAL THIS
MORNING IS YOUR WHERE OF UNEASE
WAS SPENDING TIME WITH THE.
WITH THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS.
.
BUT WITH WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU INCLUDING US TO BE INCLUDING
US IN THIS HEARING TODAY LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S NOT HAD A SEAT AT
THE TABLE HAVING PRIOR HEARINGS
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHANCE
TO GIVE YOU CAN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE. AND
HOPEFULLY I CAN DO THAT AS
DIRECTOR SHE MOTOR MENTIONED.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DMV SINCE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON TRAFFIC SAFETY ISSUES
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AS NEW
ISSUES ARISE. SAFETY IS
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING FOR
THE OUR PATROL TRAFFIC SAFETY ON
THE ROADWAYS AND THAT'S THE LENS
THROUGH WHICH WE LOOK AT
EVERYTHING.
AND SOME ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
THOUGH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT FACES
NOT ONLY CHP BUT CERTAINLY OUR
LOCAL ALLIED AGENCY PARTNERS.
WHO WILL PROBABLY BE
EXPERIENCING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
MORE THAN CHP OFFICERS FRANKLY
ARE OR THE UNCERTAINTY OF THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY?
HOW IT'S BEING USED?
IT'S SO RAPID AND IT'S RAPIDLY
DEVELOPING AND IT'S IT'S
FOR A LOT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS OUT THERE ON THE ROAD
THEY DON'T KNOW A WHOLE LOT
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY.
ANOTHER BIG CHALLENGE IS A
STATUTORY CHALLENGES
PHIL TALK ABOUT EACH OF THESE IN
TURN FIRST FALL WITH WITH
RESPECT TO THE UNCERTAINTY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW WE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN WHAT IT WHAT ARE
THEY ALLOWED TO DO?
WHAT ARE THEY REQUIRED TO DO ON
THE ROADWAYS WHAT DOES LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO IF THEY IN IRAQ
ONE OF THESE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
AS A RESULT OF THE CALL OF A
COLLISION? OR MAYBE AN
ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY HOW THEY
HANDLE THAT.
CERTAINLY THE HIGHWAY PATROL
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH THE DMV WE HAVE A
GOOD SENSE OF THE NEW REGULATORY
STRUCTURE BUT ARE A LOT OF
RALLIED AGENCY PARTNERS DON'T.
IT'S WHITE HEARINGS LIKE THIS I
THINK ARE SO CRUCIAL FOR THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY CERTAINLY
HERE.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE AND WE
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS
WITH OUR ALLIED AGENCY PARTNERS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE EIGHTIES.
WHAT IS COMING AND OTHER SCHOOLS
RESPOND TO THEM?
SOME GOOD ELEMENTS OF THE DMV
ROUTE REGULATIONS THAT WILL
CERTAINLY HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS
OUR INFORMATION THAT AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE A
PERMIT. AFTER PROVIDE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT WHERE VEHICLES
ARE BEING TESTED IN OTHER WORDS
WHAT WHAT.
WHAT ROADWAYS ARE BEING TESTED
ON WHAT TYPES OF VEHICLES?
WHEN THEY WILL BE USED THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES THAT WILL BE
TESTED THAT INFORMATION IS IS
CRUCIAL FOR FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE.
ANOTHER BIG THING FOR LAW FOR
SOME PROBLEM MOST SIGNIFICANT
ASPECT OF THE DMV REGULATIONS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE.
REQUIREMENT OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR ACTION PLAN
THAT MANUFACTURES MUST THIS MUST
SUBMIT.
THE REGULATIONS REQUIRE.
THIS INFORMATION TO BE SAID TO A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
INCLUDING CHP ALLIED AGENCIES
FAR DEPARTMENTS AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES.
.
BEFORE TESTING BEGINS IN IN ANY
AREA MATTER FACT I WORKED FOR
RIGHT NOW WE ARE REVIEWING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROPOSED LAW PERSON
INTERACTION PLAN THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED.
THE.
INTERACTION PLANS SHALL INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO IN IRAQ
DURING ENFORCEMENT EMERGENCY
SITUATION
AND SOME OF THE COMPONENTS OF
THE PLANS INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THE FOLLOWING.
HOW TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
REMOTE OPERATOR OF A VEHICLE OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES WHERE IN THE
VEHICLE TO OBTAIN THE
REGISTRATION AND INSURANCE SAY
FOR INSTANCE?
LAW ENFORCEMENT MAKES AN
ENFORCEMENT
STOP ON AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE OR IN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES INVOLVED IN
THE IN A COLLISION.
CRUCIAL BATTLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER BILL TO GET THIS
REGISTERED OWNER INFORMATION
INSURANCE INFORMATION FROM THE
VEHICLE.
HOW TO IDENTIFY IF THE VEHICLES
IN AUTONOMOUS MODE MODE AND HOW
TO SAFELY DISENGAGED THE
AUTONOMOUS MODE YOU CAN IMAGINE
A CONCERN FOR LAW PERSON ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD IS OKAY? IF I
STOP THIS AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE OF
THIS VEHICLES BEEN INVOLVED IN A
COLLISION WHAT ASSURANCE DO I
HAVE THAT IT'S GONNA REMAIN
STOPPED
AND THAT KIND OF INFORMATION IS
INCLUDED IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERACTION PLAN THAT
MANUFACTURERS HAVE TO SUBMIT.
ARE ALSO OUT OF THE TECH CAN
ENSURE THAT THE AUTONOMOUS MODE
IS DEACTIVATED. THIS ANOTHER
VERY.
IMPORTANT PRACTICAL PIECE OF
INFORMATION FOR AN OFFICER TO
HAVE BECAUSE YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
LEVEL THREE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
WHERE SOMEONE IS BEHIND THE
WHEEL WE NEED TO FIND OUT IF THE
PERSON WAS ACTUALLY DRIVING THE
VEHICLE IN CONTROLLED VEHICLE OR
FOR WAS IN AUTONOMOUS MODE.
SO I THINK THOUGH THAT
INFORMATION IS IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT FOR FOR TRAFFIC SAFETY
BUT ALSO IMPORTANT TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNDERSTAND WHAT
THESE VEHICLES CAN DO AND WHAT
THE. OFFICERS WILL DO WHEN THEY
INTERACT WITH.
THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PLANS SHALL BE REVIEWED AND
UPDATED AS CHANGES ARE NEEDED.
WITHIN TEN DAYS OF APPROVAL THE
TESTING APPLICATION THEY'LL BE
POSTED ON THE SEAT PIECE WEBSITE
THE TO BE NEED TO BE POSTED AS
WELL ON THE MANUFACTURER'S
WEBSITE SO THERE TILL THE VERY
ACCESSIBLE.
NOW THE OTHER BIG CHALLENGE WE
HAD THAT I REFERENCED IS A
STATUTORY CHALLENGE WE HAVE.
CALIFORNIA'S YOU CODE WAS NOT
WRITTEN WITH AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
IN MIND I THINK HE'LL KNOW THAT
AND.
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS IN
CONSULTATION WITH.
DEPARTMENT VEHICLES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKING AT THE
VEHICLE CODE AND HOW TO APPLY
HOW WE APPLY THE CURRENT
STATUTORY SCHEME TO AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES
AND WE THINK WE HAVE A GOOD PLAN
WE THINK WE HAVE.
.
VERY GOOD APPLICATION WE CAN
ENSURE TRAFFIC SAFETY BY GETTING
VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD BY ISSUING
ENFORCEMENT APPROPRIATE FORSMAN
DOCUMENTATION TO.
MANUFACTURERS ARE OPERATORS OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IF NECESSARY.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO PASSED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SOME
SPECIFIC NEW.
LEGISLATION RELATING TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
VIEW CODE SECTION THIRTY EIGHT
SEVEN FIFTY.
BE TOO REQUIRES.
OF LEVEL THREE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE IF SOMEONE IS NOT IN THE
DRIVER SEAT AND NOT MONITORING
AND NOT CABLE OF TAKING CONTROL
THAT'S A NEW INFRACTION.
IF WE ENCOUNTER THAT ALSO IN
THAT SAME SECTION IT REALLY.
PROHIBITS A MANUFACTURER FROM
TESTING WITHOUT PROPER INSURANCE
AND LICENSE
THERE'S ANOTHER SECTION WHICH
PROHIBITS THE OPERATION OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ON THE
ROADWAYS WITHOUT AN APPROVED DMB
APPLICATIONS OF. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY ACTED THE
MINISTRATIONS ALREADY.
APPROVED SOME LEGISLATION THAT
IS VERY HELPFUL IN THIS AREA.
SOMETHING ELSE WERE DRAWING UPON
WITH THIS WILL STATUTORY ISSUE
IS IS EXPERIENCES AND OTHER
STATES YOU'VE SEEN SOME VERY
HIGH PROFILE INCIDENTS OFFICE
INVOLVING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
VEHICLES WITH DRIVER ASSIST
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AND AW
ENFORCEMENT CLEAN THE HIGHWAY
PATROL WE'VE WORKED OUR WAY
THROUGH SOME OF THESE IN MANY
CASES. ITS DRIVER ASSIST
TECHNOLOGY AND THE DRIVER IS
STILL FIRMLY IN CONTROL AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENS IN THAT VEHICLE SO SO
ENFORCEMENT ACTION WE TAKE
ISRAEL IS RELATIVELY CLEAR IN
THOSE SITUATIONS.
SOMETHING ELSE THE CHP IS DOING
IS IS WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
ON WORKING GROUP'S FOR NHTSA AND.
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATION OF MOTOR VEHICLE
ADMINISTRATORS.
OUR EXPERIENCES THAT WE'RE
SEEING OUT ON THE ROAD AND OUR
INVOLVEMENT IN THESE WORKING
GROUPS WILL HELP INFORM.
I THINK THE INVOLVEMENT WE HAVE
WITH D. M. V. AND THE
DISCUSSIONS WE ARE HAVING WITH
THE MINISTRATION AND YOU'LL BE
ON ON.
POSSIBLY LOOKING AREAS WHERE THE
VEHICLE CODE NEEDS TO BE MORE
FOCUSED TO ADDRESS AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE ISSUES.
I'M AS A NUMBER OF AB IS ON THE
ROAD TO MULTIPLY IN THE USES
EXPAND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DRAW
ON THIS EXPERIENCE IN OUR
INVOLVEMENT TO AUTO INSURER
TRAFFIC SAFETY ON THE ROADWAYS.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO JD
THEM WILL HAVE A ROUND OF
QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHORE FRAZIER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JUDY RUSSELL CHO AND
I'M THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. OR A
SEVENTY EIGHT.
I'M I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ISSUE THAT IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO SAN
FRANCISCO.
CITIES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
ALREADY HAVE COMPANIES TESTING
IF HE'S ON OUR STREETS. WHILE
WAITING FOR THE BUS THE SATURDAY
AFTERNOON I WATCHED NAVY CIRCLE
MY BLOCK THREE TIMES. AND THEN
YOU KNOW MANEUVER ITS WAY AROUND
AND IF WE REALLY MADE ME REALIZE
YOU KNOW THIS IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW AND IT'S ON THE GROUNDS.
PROPOSED FEDERAL LEGISLATION
COULD ALLOW THE EACH
MANUFACTURER DEPLOY UP TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND AV'S AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THREE YEARS.
MANY OF WHICH WE EXPECT IN URBAN
AREAS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO.
TODAY PUBLIC ATTENTION
CONCERNING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
IS FOCUSED ON THE VEHICLE ITSELF.
MORE THOUGHT MUST BE GIVEN TO
THE ENVIRONMENT OF THESE
VEHICLES WILL OPERATE AND AND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AROUND THEM.
WITH AV IS WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
A ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO RETHINK OUR STREETS.
TO ADDRESS CRITICAL ISSUES LIKE
TRAFFIC SAFETY CONGESTION
MOBILITY AND EQUITY.
AS A MANAGER OF ALL GROUND
TRANSPORTATION IN SAN FRANCISCO
THAT'S OF MTA IS CHARGED WITH
OVERSEEING A SAFE EFFECTIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
WE SUPPORT INNOVATION AND
BELIEVES AND THE LONG TERM
AUTOMATION CAN REALLY HELP
REDUCE A LOT OF THE DANGEROUS
DRIVING BEHAVIORS THAT WE SEE ON
THE STREETS.
AB IS COMMITTED TO HELP US
ACHIEVE SEVERAL HORSES CITIES
GUIDING TRANSPORTATION POLICY IS
INCLUDING VISION ZERO OUR
EFFORTS AND ALL TRAFFIC
FATALITIES ON CITY STREETS. AS
WELL AS OUR TRANSIT FIRST POLICY
WHICH PRIORITIZES MASS TRANSIT
WALKING AND BIKING OVER SINGLE
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE TRIPS.
WE SEE THE POTENTIAL FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BUT ONLY IF
REGULATED CORRECTLY.
A PROACTIVE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ROLE IN SAFEGUARDING
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IS CRUCIAL.
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF AB IS
ON OUR STREETS.
OPPOSES A VARIETY OF ISSUES FOR
A CITY MUST BUT A CITY MUST
CONSIDER BUT TODAY WILL FOCUS ON
SAFETY.
THE TRAGIC FATALITY IN ARIZONA
HAS BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO THE
FRONT OF ALL OF OUR MINDS.
AND THE REALITY THAT A THESE ARE
NOT A SILVER BULLET TO SAFETY
WITHOUT FURTHER TESTING AND
THOUGHTFUL REGULATION HAS BECOME
APPARENT.
WITH A POTENTIALLY SWIFT PACE OF
INTRODUCTION OF EIGHTIES ON OUR
CITY STREETS WE BELIEVE THE
MANUFACTURERS NEED TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH CITIES TO ENSURE
THAT THE FIRST AB IS DEPLOYED
WILL SAFELY INTERACT WITH OTHER
ROAD USERS. INCLUDED IN PUBLIC
TRANSIT VEHICLES AND PEOPLE
WALKING AND BIKING ON OUR
STREETS.
DURING THE PERIOD WHERE
AUTONOMOUS AND NON AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES SHARE THE STREET. AB IS
MUST BE ESPECIALLY SENSITIVE TO
THE NEIGHBORHOOD CONTACTS AND
SHOULD WORK WITH CITIES TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE AREAS
FOR TESTING AND DEPLOYMENT.
TODAY ANSWER NAY LINGERS AROUND
THREE CRITICAL REGULATORY ISSUES
RELATED TO SAFETY THAT OFFER
THEIR DISCUSS.
THE FIRST IS MAINTAINING CONTROL
OF OUR LOCAL STREETS.
THE SECOND IS DEVELOPING
EFFECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERACTION PLANS AND THE THIRD
IS ACCESS TO DATA ABOUT HOW
ATHEISTS WILL OPERATE ON CITY
STREETS.
IT'S CRITICAL THE CITY'S
MAINTAIN LOCAL CONTROL OF OUR
STREETS EVEN A THREE RELY ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SET AB
DESIGN OPERATION AND PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS.
WITH THE CURRENT FEDERAL
LEGISLATION DISCUSSED HERE TODAY
ON CITIES AND STATES COULD BE
PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL RULES AND
COULD LOSE THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE THE BASIC RULES OF THE
ROAD. THIS COULD CREATE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO A. B.
TECHNOLOGY ACROSS THE COUNTRY OF
THAT LACK SENSITIVITY TO LOCAL
CONTACTS.
TO GIVE THE LOCAL EXAMPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT IS AGAINST THE LAW
TO DRIVE THROUGH A CROSSWALK
ONCE PEDESTRIAN HAS ENTERED.
RECENTLY A CRUISE VEHICLE
OPERATING IN AUTONOMOUS MODE
WITH THE TEST DRIVER WAS
TICKETED FOR DRIVING THROUGH A
CROSSWALK AFTER A PEDESTRIAN HAD
ALREADY ENTERED.
LUCKILY THE AV DID NOT HIT THE
PERSON CROSSING THE STREET.
HOWEVER THE FACT REMAINS THAT IN
AB WAS NOT PROGRAMMED TO.
TO FOLLOW OUR LOCAL TRAFFIC
LAWS
AND TO ENSURE THAT SAM CISCO
REMAINS A SAFE CITY FOR ALL ROAD
USERS INCLUDING THOSE LOCKED
LAWFULLY WALKING ACROSS THE
STREET. WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT INCIDENTS LIKE THIS DO
NOT CONTINUE AND THAT IF YOU
FOLLOW THE RULES OF THE ROAD.
SECOND WE NEED TO ENSURE CLEAR
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN AB
MANUFACTURES AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
IT'S ABSOLUTE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND FIRST RESPONDERS AND KNOW
HOW TO INTERACT WITH AB IS IN
THE EVENT OF A TRAFFIC INCIDENT
OR COLLISION.
FOR EXAMPLE ONE AB RECOGNIZE
WHEN A POLICE OFFICER IS PULLING
IT OVER. HOW WILL THE FIRST
RESPOND OR KNOW WHO TO CALL IN
THERE'S A COLLISION WHO WILL
PICK UP THE PHONE ON THE OTHER
AND AND WHERE WILL THEY BE
LOCATED?
WILL THEY HAVE A REAL TIME
CONTROL OVER THE AB.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT CURRENTLY REMAIN
UNANSWERED.
WERE ENCOURAGED TO THE DMV
REGULATIONS FOR DRIVERLESS AB
PERMITS.
REQUIRE THE MANUFACTURERS TO
SUBMIT THESE PLAN.
THE REGULATIONS ARE GOOD START
BUT WE BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THEY
CAN BE FURTHER STRENGTHENED.
IT'S INCREASINGLY CLEAR THE
EFFECTIVE AND MEANINGFUL PLANS
MUST BE JOINTLY DEVELOPED
DEVELOPED BY THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR.
IN MARCH SENSES BECAUSE MAYOR
MARK FARRELL CONVENED A ROUND
TABLE TO SPECIFICALLY DISCUSS AB
IS A PUBLIC SAFETY.
PARTICIPANTS INCLUDED
MANUFACTURERS SUCH AS CREWS WHO
WERE LEFT
WHEN MOSES UC'S AND PHANTOM AUTO.
AND SAN FRANCISCO FIRST
RESPONDERS INCLUDING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT FIRE DEPARTMENT
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT NCHC.
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT CITIES CONCERNS WERE
HEARD BY COMPANIES BEFORE THEY
DEPLOYED DEPLOYED AB IS ON THE
STREETS. AND ADDITIONALLY HOLD
ON EDUCATE THE CITY'S PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS ON THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND
DISCUSS THE COMPANY'S APPROACH
TO PUBLIC SAFETY TO FURTHER CUT
TO INITIATE THIS DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR.
AS A RESULT OF THIS WORK WE
DEVELOP SEVERAL SPECIFIC POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAN IMPROVE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION.
INCLUDING IMPROVING THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS BETWEEN
MANUFACTURERS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
CLEAR PROTOCOL FOR COMMUNICATION
WITH THE REMOTE OPERATOR. OF AN
AV WHO'S AVAILABLE AT ALL TIMES.
SPLIT THE DIRECTIONS ON
INTERACTING WITH A VIEWS IN THE
EVENT OF A COLLISION INCLUDING
SAFETY HAZARDS AND REAL TIME
NOTIFICATION TO CITIES ONE
ANYTHING COVERED IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION PLANNED
CHANGES. AND I'M HAPPY TO TO
FURTHER DISCUSS ANY THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS LATER.
IN ADDITION A STRENGTHENING OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION PLANS
WE'VE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE
INFORMATION SHARING BETWEEN THE
COMPANIES AND THE CITY.
US SUCH TOPICS INCLUDE TRAFFIC
AND PARKING VIOLATION PROTOCOL
STOLEN VEHICLE PROTOCOL UNMARKED
CAR INTERACTIONS TRANSIT
PROTOCOLS DATA RECORDER AND
OTHER POST COLLISION POLICIES.
AND THIS IS JUST A PREVIEW OF
THE LONG LIST OF TOPICS.
UP THE SERVICES GO POLICE
DEPARTMENT WILL CONVENE THEIR
FIRST WORKING GROUP OF
MANUFACTURERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS TO BEGIN TACKLING
THESE TOPICS IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS.
LASTLY ONE CLOSE BY DISCUSSING
THE IMPORTANCE OF DATA TO ENSURE
AND ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY.
CITIES NEED DATA TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS.
CURRENTLY THE ONLY PROVISION FOR
DATA SHARING IN THE NEW DMV
REGULATIONS IS AN ANNUAL REPORT
SUMMARIZING DISENGAGEMENT
SUBMITTED TO THE DMV.
THIS REPORT LIVES IN TIME
UNLOCKS KEY INFORMATION CITIES
NEED TO BE RESPONSIVE.
USEFUL DATA FROM AVIANS INCLUDES
ANONYMIZE DETAILS ABOUT VEHICLE
MOVEMENT.
ROADWAY ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS
WHEN CRASHES OCCUR AND EVEY
DISENGAGEMENT WERE HUMAN DRIVERS
MUST TAKE OVER THAT THOMAS
DRIVING SYSTEM.
AMONG OTHERS
A THIRD PARTY ENTITIES SUCH AS
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
CITY TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
ARE NOT SO HAVE DEVELOPED DATA
SHARING PLATFORMS IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THAT CAN WORK FOR BOTH AB
MANUFACTURES AND PUBLIC DECISION
MAKERS. AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO SUPPORT
THESE DATA SHOWING EFFORTS.
BUT TO FOCUS ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THIS THIS AFTERNOON
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FOR
THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THE PANEL.
ASIA OPPORTUNITY.
THIS I HAVE A COUPLE WRITTEN
DOWN ON MR WITH THE DMV AND AND
WORK OUR WAY.
THROUGH.
.
JEAN BERNARD.
HOW DOES THE DMV USE THE
DISENGAGEMENT REPORTS?
SO THAT WE NEED TO DISENGAGE
REPORTS TO TO MONITOR HALL THEIR
TECHNOLOGY IS PROGRESSING AND
ALSO WHEN A COMPANY DOES APPLY
FOR A PERMIT WE USE THAT AS AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO EVALUATE. A
HOW THE PROGRESS THE COMPANIES
MAKING ON THE TECHNOLOGY SO WE
USE IT AS INFORMATION PURPOSES
TO FURTHER GET INFORMATION. OUT
FROM THE COMPANIES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
PROHIBITING MANUFACTURERS FROM
CHARGING PASSENGERS ONE THE
TESTING PHASE.
WELL FOR THAT THAT THAT WAS
PRESS TO SEGMENT AT TESTING FROM
DEPLOYMENT.
IF THE COMPANY IS CHART ALLOWED
TO CHARGE A FEE DURING TESTING A
COMEY COULD CONTINUE
CONTINUOUSLY TASSELS THERE OUT
EVERITT THE PLANES WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMPANIES. TESTED
AND THEN MOVED ON TO DEPLOYMENT.
IS TO KANSEN CHU.
PITCHER I JUST THOUGHT OH HOW
THE QUESTION FOUR. AND JD.
AND DR THE SENIOR ANALYST SO
YOU'RE. NOT WHEN WE HOW CLOSE
ARE AUTONOMOUS VERY COOL ON THE
ROAD.
BIKE LARGE. QUANTITY DO YOU SEE
THAT IT WILL INCREASE OR
DECREASE THE LOCAL TRAFFIC.
I WOULD IMAGINE THE
INTRODUCTION OF ANY NEW VEHICLES
ON THE STREETS WOULD INCREASE
TRAFFIC.
AND CONGESTION.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR CITIES YOU KNOW
AND. IF WE DO HAVE MORE DATA
ABOUT.
THE MOVEMENT OF THESE VEHICLES
ON THE STREET TO. I'M DESIGN
ACCORDINGLY BUT I THINK AT THE
BEGINNING.
WE WOULD EXPECT FULL TRAFFIC
WHO MARK AND CHRIS WILSON POINT
WE KIND OF. MORAL FIFTH THOMAS
SMITH VEHICLE ON THE ROAD.
IF NOTHING ELSE CHANGES THEN I'D
SAY YES MAHOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE BACK TO RUN THE
DMV.
SO WHEN DOES THE DMV ANTICIPATE
THEY WILL THEY WILL BEGIN
ISSUING REGULATIONS FOR TESTING
AND DEPLOYMENT VEHICLES OVER TEN
THOUSAND POUNDS.
SO AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NOT BEEN
FIFTH BEGUN WORKING ON THIS WE
WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT THE SAFETY
AND REGULATORY CONDITIONS ABOUT
SORT OF WITH THIS SO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NOT BEGUN THAT.
LAST QUESTION TO THE DMV IS.
IS THE DMV CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF APPLICATIONS TO TEST
DRIVE WAS CARS ON PUBLIC ROADS.
I KNOW THIS SHOWS THAT THE
COMPANIES ARE BEING VERY DELIVER
TIP IN.
LOOKING AT THAT AT TIMES
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY IN TERMS OF
SOME MEAN AN APPLICATION.
NO AT THIS TIME WE'RE NOT
CONCERNED OKAY THANK YOU.
SO PROCEEDS BEING RICH.
IS A CSP GIVING ENOUGH
INFORMATION FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS IN THEIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION PLANTS.
BUT WE WE HAVE THE FIRST PLAN
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY REVIEWING
AND.
.
WHEN THE PROCESS OF THAT IT'S
NOT IT'S AN AND IT'S NOT ONLY
THE INFORMATION JUST HAVING A
DISCUSSION WITH THE ASSISTANT
CHIEF IS REVIEWING THE PLAN
ITSELF.
IT'S MAKING SURE THE INFORMATION
IS IN A.
USABLE READILY ACCESSIBLE
FORMAT THAT'S KINDA HALF THE
BATTLE AND AND PULL IT ALL
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE IT'S GONNA
BE EASY TO UNDERSTAND FOR THE
OFFICER ON THE SIDE THE ROAD. IF
WE NEED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WILL CERTAINLY ASK THE
MANUFACTURE FOR THAT INFORMATION
BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT I'M BEING
TOLD IS THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED ON THE ON
THIS FOR.
PERFECT.
SO WHAT IF ANYTHING DOES THE CHP
DO IF THEY LEARN A COMPANY WILL
BE TESTING AN AUTOMATED VEHICLE
IN AN AREA WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
WELL THE FIRST THING WE WOULD DO
IT IS IS MAKE SURE THAT THEY
MANUFACTURE HAS PROVIDED THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION THAT
REQUIRED THE REGULATIONS BOTH
THE INFORMATION THAT GOES ALL
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
GOVERNMENTS ABOUT THAT THERE WHO
WHERE WEB WHEN WHAT WHY.
AND THEN ALSO OF COURSE MAKING
SURE ALL THE INFORMATION FOR THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
INTERACTION PLAN IS THERE. AND
THEN WE WOULD WITH SOME THAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE ACTUALLY JT
MADE REFERENCE TO IT TO SIT DOWN
WITH OUR LOCAL ALLIED AGENCY
PARTNERS. AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO TALK ABOUT OKAY.
ARE WE PREPARING FOR THIS IS
MAKE SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
LIST TO MAKE SURE WE ALL HAVE
THE SAME ENFORCEMENT POSTURE AND
CERTAINLY STAY IN TOUCH WITH
EACH OTHER AND SHARE EXPERIENCES
A BILL DRAWN THOSE EXPERIENCES
SO WE. ARE DOING THINGS THE
RIGHT WAY AND AND RELYING ON
EACH OTHER.
SO HERE'S ONE OF THEM MIGHT BE
OF INTEREST.
HOW WITH THE CHP RESPONDED
SAYING AUTOMATED VEHICLE IN THE
AREA WHERE THEY HAVE NOT
SPECIFIED?
BUT THEY'VE.
WOULD BE TESTING.
THAT YOU KNOW ACTION THERE'S
ACTUALLY AT ONE OF THE SECTIONS
I REFERENCED.
.
COULD POTENTIALLY ADDRESS THAT
VERY THING I MEAN IT'S AN
INFRACTION TO BE TESTING AVR
PUBLIC ROADWAYS WITHOUT AN
APPROVED APPLICATION.
IF FOR INSTANCE THERE'S A
SITUATION WHERE A APPROVED A
LICENSEE OR SOMEONE HAS APPROVED
PERMIT AND THEY'RE JUST
OPERATING MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
OUTSIDE THE GEOGRAPHICAL
BOUNDARY WHERE THEY. WERE THAT
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED WE WOULD
CERTAINLY REFER THAT INFORMATION
TO THE DMV TO TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE REGULATORY ACTION
AGAINST THAT.
MANUFACTURE.
SO ONE WAS QUESTION FOR THE CHP.
SO YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE OF.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE IS DONDE
TO IMPROVE THE.
ROLL OUT DOES HE'S PRE NEED ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORIZATION TO
REMOVE.
AUTOMATED VEHICLES THAT THERE
HAVE NOT BEEN PERMITTED TO
TESTING CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
OF EVALUATING WHERE IN THE
VEHICLE CODE.
ADJUSTMENTS MAY NEED TO BE MADE
TOO TO MAKE IT EXPLICIT THAT
BOTH THE ENFORCEMENT ACTION AND
AND OTHER.
AUTHORIZATIONS APPLY IN THE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE CONTEXT.
.
FOR RIGHT NOW WE IT IN IN SOME
PLACES IS PUTTING A SQUARE PEG
IN A ROUND HOLE.
BUT WE DO WE THINK WE DO HAVE
AN APPROACH TO TAKE TO GET AN
UNSAFE AB OFF THE ROAD SIR.
THANK YOU MEN WERE GONNA GO WITH
YOU.
WORKING CALIFORNIA DUE TO BETTER
ADVOCATE ITS POSITION ON
AUTOMATED VEHICLES IN WASHINGTON
DC.
I WOULD SAY THAT.
AT LEAST YOUR.
TWO SENATORS ARE DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB OF. ENSURING THAT
IF THE SENATE DOES MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THE BILL THAT.
THE CONCERNS THAT I'VE HEARD.
EXPRESSED HERE TODAY ARE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT.
WITH A WITH ANY FEDERAL BILL
THAT OUT DOES.
GET NAKED AND SIGNED INTO LAW BY
THE PRESIDENT.
SWIMMER BEEN A WHAT IS IT AND A
SEAL DOING TO PROTECT STATES
RIGHTS ON AUTOMATED.
VEHICLE TESTING
ALSO SHIRT SO.
.
I I THINK THAT QUESTION BOILS
DOWN TO.
REALLY.
AS STATES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
CURRENTLY ON.
ISSUE.
AND AN OPERATOR'S LICENSE TO A
HUMAN TO OPERATE A MOTOR VEHICLE
HOW DOES THAT AUTHORITY EXTEND
TO WHEN THAT.
OPERATOR IS A A SOFTWARE ARM
AND I THINK WE HAVE BEEN.
ADVOCATING AND LOBBYING ON
STATES BEHALF TO ENSURE THAT
STATES RETAIN THAT AUTHORITY
GOING FORWARD.
AS AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ARE
INTRODUCED.
FOR COMMERCIAL SALE.
JD WE HAD OF HIS COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
A WHAT IF ANY PREPARATIONS DOES
SAN FRANCISCO MAKE ONE IS MADE
AWARE OF TESTING BEING CONDUCTED
ON HIS PUBLIC STREETS.
YEAH THIS POINT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
DOING ANYTHING THAT.
.
AND PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT WE
WOULD OTHERWISE WE STOLE ON YOU
KNOW AS I MENTION BEFORE THE
EXAMPLE WHERE CHRIS WAS TICKETED
THAT WAS JUST OUR OFFICERS OUT
DOING WHAT THEY USUALLY DO
MAKING SURE THAT ANY VEHICLE ON
THE ROAD IS FOLLOWING.
FOLLOWING LOCAL TRAFFIC LAWS.
YEAH.
SO NO PUBLIC GIVE INFORMATION
AND.
DRIVERS VEHICLES AND MESSAGING
BOARDS ANYTHING THAT I'M WE HAD
NOT BY ISSUE THE PUBLIC.
WE HAVE NOT YET DISCUSSED UP
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD THAT WE SHOULD.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MEN ARE YOU GETTING ADEQUATE
INFORMATION FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERACTION REPORTS.
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
YEAH YOU KNOW THIS THAT THE MERS
ROUNDTABLE IT DISCUSSED.
BEFORE WITH OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THE MANUFACTURERS
I'M A LOT OF THE CONVERSATION
HAS NATURALLY BEEN AROUND THESE
LAW ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION
PLANS.
.
WE THINK THAT THERE'S JUST SO
MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THAT
WE THINK THAT IT'S A REALLY GOOD
FRAMEWORK THAT WE HAVE NOW THAT
THERE IS THERE IS MORE THAT WE
COULD. REQUIRE A MORE EXPLICITLY
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE YEAH I'D
LIKE A MONTHS NOTICE WHEN BEFORE
OF THE AND AB IS GOING TO BE
TESTING OR DEPLOYING ON THEIR
STREETS RATHER THAN GETTING A
NOTICE WHEN IT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING.
A LOT OF THIS IS HAPPENING AT
THE STATE LEVEL YOU KNOW LIKE
THE CHP WILL BE NOTIFIED. BUT
IT'S IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHO
WITH THE LOCAL LEVEL WILL BE
NOTIFIED AND ONE. AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE MAYOR'S OFFICE AND
OUR POLICE CHIEF KNOW IN ADVANCE
WHEN DID VEHICLES WILL BE.
.
TESTING ON OUR STREETS AND THAT
SO WE CAN.
.
PREPARE ACCORDINGLY.
CYNICISM.
I COULD PLAN THE NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE PANEL.
MR WAS FROM.
I APOLOGIZE THAT I JUST WHAT
CAME IN SO MAYBE THIS WAS OR
EVEN ANSWER BUT CAN IT WHAT
OTHER STATES HAVE.
WHAT OTHER STATES DOING IN
THERE ARE GOOD THINGS AND WHERE
THE STATE'S TWO IN THERE? AS A
GOOD.
IF ANYONE COULD ANSWER THAT.
.
BEEN HOT FOR THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATURES.
.
SO ON OUR WEBSITE.
YOU WILL SEE THAT WE HAVE
STATED THAT TWENTY TWO STATES I
HAVE ACTED PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TEN GOVERNORS HAVE SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT RELATE TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
BUT I WOULD COUCH THAT WITH.
.
DID THAT COVERS A WIDE RANGE OF
POTENTIAL LEGISLATION FROM
ANYTHING FROM OFF FUNDING.
A CONNECTED VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
PILOT PROGRAM TO SOMETHING AS
SPECIFIC AS THE AYE REGULATIONS
ISSUED BY THE CALIFORNIA DMV.
SO REALLY YOU HAVE I WOULD SAY
WHAT IS MAYBE A BIT MORE THAN A
HANDFUL OF STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA NEVADA COLORADO.
FLORIDA MICHIGAN AND OFF TOM I
HAD THAT HAVE REALLY.
GONE MAYBE TO THE NEXT STEP IN
TERMS OF.
EITHER PASSING LEGISLATION OR
HAVING THEIR DOT YOUR D. AND B.
ISSUE OP MORE SPECIFIC RULES OF
THE ROAD IF YOU WILL.
THERE ARE IN CERTAIN STATES.
WHERE WE HAVE?
WHERE GOVERNOR HAS ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT PROMPTS THE
DOT OR THE DMB DEPENDING UPON
THE STATE AYE THERE IT'S IT'S A
BIT UNCLEAR BECAUSE THERE'S MUCH
MORE LEEWAY GIVE INTO THAT
EXECUTIVE AGENCY WHEREAS IN?
THE STATE'S I MENTIONED EARLIER
I YOU HAVE MORE SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION THAT PUTS OUT.
CIVIC REQUIREMENTS ON THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OFF FOR HOW ANY
RULES OF THE ROAD I SHOULD BE
WRITTEN AND WHAT THEY SHOULD
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
JUST SO TWO QUICK FOLLOW UP TO
US IN TERMS OF BEST PRACTICE ARE
THERE SOME STATES THAT HAVE.
ITEM GOOD DONE IT THAT WE SHOULD
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
AND TO THE PRINCIPLES WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD THAT FACTOR IN TO OUR
DECISIONS.
SO I THINK ARE THE BIGGEST
QUESTION THAT WAS ANSWERED.
VERY RECENTLY BY A CALIFORNIA
WAS WHETHER OR NOT TESTING
SHOULD TAKE PLACE WITH A.
.
PERSON IN THE DRIVER SEAT OR
WITHOUT ALMOND PRIOR TO THAT WAS
KIND OF A QUESTION WHERE YOU HAD
SOME STATES ARE THAT WERE
ALLOWING TESTING TO GO FORWARD
WITHOUT AND SOME STATES.
THAT WERE NOT ALLOWING IT TO GO
FORWARD AND WE'VE SEEN A
MOVEMENT TOWARDS MANY STATES
INCLUDING NOW CALIFORNIA ARE
MOVING TOWARDS ALLOWING TESTING.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE DEAR TO
YOUR DMB TO ALLOW TESTING TO GO
FORWARD WITHOUT AN OPERATOR IN
THAT SEAT BUT STILL REQUIRING.
AYE SOME TYPE OF LINK BETWEEN
EITHER A PERSON IN THE VEHICLE
OR SOMEONE OUTSIDE OF THE
VEHICLE THAT IS ABLE TO BRING
THAT VEHICLE I TO A STOP.
OR REMOVE IT FROM THE ROADWAY I
SHOULD BE AUTOMATED DRIVING
SYSTEM ARE NOT BE ABLE TO
OPERATE IN THAT THE CONDITION
THAT IT'S BUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THEN WHAT I'M HEARING
TO TODAY'S A POSSIBILITY.
.
JEAN IN AMBER ARE THEN MAYBE WE
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON ON ON. A ROLL OUT
ANNOUNCEMENT OF FOR THE PUBLIC
ALSO JUST
BECAUSE.
I THINK THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
KNOW THIS INTO.
TECHNOLOGY AND THEY NEED TO BE
WARY ALSO JUST JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT USED TO IT.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE CAN LOOK
AT THAT. THAT ALSO RICH I THINK
YOU AND I'VE TALKED EARLIER ON
ABOUT THE THE.
TALKING TO THE MANUFACTURES
ABOUT A MASTER SHOT OFF.
WHEN I USED TO RACE WE HAD A
MASTER SHUT OFF IN THE BACK OF
THE CAR. WHO'S JUST TO PUSH OFF
IT DISABLED IT COMPLETELY. I
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
HIMSELF SAFETY OF NOT ONLY THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT ALSO THE THE
PUBLIC IN ITSELF.
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR COMING
UP THIS AFTERNOON. REFORMATION
WAS MOST HELPFUL THANK YOU.
RECALL THE SECOND PANEL UP.
WE HAVE JUDGE JEREMY MERTZ VICE
PRESIDENT WESTERN REGION
AMERICAN INSURANCE ASSOCIATION.
ROSEMARY XIN SIOBHAN.
PRESIDENT CONSUMERS.
FOR AUTO RIB RELIABILITY AND
SAFETY.
SAYS SHOWN SENIOR STAFF
TECHNOLOGISTS ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND VERY
BROAD WITH THE TEAMSTERS.
BUT HEAD THEN START WITH GERMANY
AND A WORKER WITH.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SHARE
MEMORIES ABOUT THE AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AT
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
ATV SAFETY.
I'M RARELY ON A PANEL.
FOR CONSUMERS.
SO IT'S A IT'S A.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
AND AND AND I THINK THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR
INDIVIDUAL POLICYHOLDERS AS A.
B. TECHNOLOGY.
EVOLVES AND THERE'S A A
DEPLOYMENT.
WE WE HAVE A AN IMPORTANT VOICE.
A I A.
IT IS THAT WE REPRESENT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
TNC PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE READ
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
INDIRECT PREMIUM.
AND WE ARE AN ACTIVE ADVOCATE.
AT BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL.
FOR ATV SAFETY.
PARTICULARLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
OPERATIONAL SAFETY WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE THINK THAT I MEET NEEDS
TO BE TESTED AND PROVEN TO
PROVIDE AND ENHANCE SAFETY FOR
DRIVERS PASSENGERS AND
PEDESTRIANS.
WE THINK THAT ON THIS IS THE
PARAMOUNT PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE.
IN DEVELOPING THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SUGGESTIONS TO FURTHER ON THIS
GOAL FIRST OF ALL I THINK. ON
THE CORNERSTONE OF AIDS E. V.
PUBLIC POLICY IS THE NEED FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO MEET ALL
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL SAFETY
MOTOR VEHICLE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS INCLUDES AMONGST MANY OTHER
THINGS
PASSENGER RESTRAINTS CRASH
WORTHINESS DRIVER RELIABILITY.
AND FOLLOWING THE RULES OF THE
ROAD.
ANYTHING LAST IN THE
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY OF AB IS
WILL BE IN DOUBT AND THE WE
BELIEVE AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
THE POINT'S BEEN MADE THE PUBLIC
ACCEPTANCE.
WILL SUFFER.
SECONDLY.
WE STRONGLY ADVOCATE FOR ROBUST
EFFORTS.
TO HARDEN ATVS AGAINST CYBER
ATTACKS AND HACKING.
.
WITH TELEMATICS DEDICATED SHORT
RANGE
VEHICLE TO VEHICLE AND VEHICLE
TO INFRASTRUCTURE COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS.
AND THERE ARE MYRIAD OF AVENUES
OF BAD ACTORS TO ATTACK
INDIVIDUAL VEHICLES AN ENTIRE
SYSTEM.
A MASS SYNCRETIZED SYNCHRONIZED.
CYBER ATTACK ON ATVS
AND COULD HAVE CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES I I DON'T THINK
WE'VE SEEN ON IN VEHICLES BEFORE.
PUBLIC POLICY IN THIS ARENA
MUST SEEK TO VIGOROUSLY GUARD
AGAINST THIS.
THIRD AND PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANT THE INSURERS.
IS KNOWLEDGE AND THE DATA THAT.
CAN BE USED TO DERIVE THIS
KNOWLEDGE.
IN ORDER TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
SAFE TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT IS NOT
SAFE TECHNOLOGY IN THIS APPLIES
WHETHER IT'S INSURES TRYING TO.
CREATE THE MOST ACCURATE RATES
FOR PRODUCTS CONSUMERS DECIDING
WHICH ATVS TO USER BY.
AB DEVELOP DEVELOPERS ATTEMPTING
TO IMPROVE PERFORMANCE.
OR PUBLIC POLICY DECISION MAKERS
LAWMAKERS
CREATING VEHICLE SAFETY LAWS
I'M FUNDAMENTALLY WE CANNOT
MANAGE A BUT WE DO NOT MEASURE
IN DATA AND KNOWLEDGE DRIVEN
FROM IT ARE THE ELEMENTAL
ASPECTS TO IMPROVED AB SAFETY
AND AGAIN. PUBLIC ACCEPTANCE
I'M FIRST ENSURE SPECIFICALLY.
ACCESS TO THE BROADEST RANGE OF
OPERATIONAL DATA WILL HELP US DO
OUR JOBS AND IDENTIFYING PRICING
IN MITIGATING RISK.
THIS INCLUDES KNOWING WHEN
SYSTEMS DISENGAGE WARN DRIVERS
HAVE LAPSES IDENTIFY LAPSES
I'M OR FAIL A TO IDENTIFY
HAZARDS.
INSURERS WILL CERTAINLY GET
THIS DATA.
AS CLAIMS ARISE BUT IF WE'RE
GOOD TO GET OUT FRONT OF THIS WE
NEED AND AND BE ABLE OFFER
PRODUCTS. THAT A PROPERLY PRICED
PRODUCTS WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS DATA ON THE FRONT END.
IT HELPS US TO BOND CREE
CAPITAL FORMATION ON AND TO
CREATE AGAIN POLICY PRODUCTS FOR.
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY
ONCE THERE'S A ROLL OUT. ON THE
DEPLOYMENT OF AB TECHNOLOGY AND
FINALLY I THINK.
.
THE INSURANCE MARKETPLACE CAN
SPEAK UNTO THE SAFETY OF
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES BY
AVOIDING CROSS SUBSIDIES THAT
HARM BETTER SAFER TECHNOLOGIES.
WHILE BENEFITING READER WEAKER
AND LESS SAFE TECHNOLOGIES.
I THINK IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
ALREADY BUT THE DISENGAGEMENT
REPORTS WE THINK ARE.
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS.
DATA ACQUISITION AND THESE
REPORTS HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW
THE RISK OF SYSTEM SHUT DOWNS OR
HANDOFFS.
AND I THINK IN PARTICULAR ON
THE USABILITY OF THESE REPORTS
ON THAT THEY PROVIDE INFORMATION
ON THERE REALLY INSTRUCTS NOT
ONLY THAT IT JUST ENGAGED BUT
WHY DISENGAGED.
AND ALLOWS UNINSURED UNDERSTAND
WHICH TECHNOLOGIES ON WORK
BETTER AND ARE SAFER.
AND THEN FINALLY I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION AROUND
THIS.
AT BOTH THE DMB REGULATORY
PROCESS.
AND ON CAUGHT OTHER STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS IN HEARINGS BUT WE
DO BELIEVE.
THAT.
LEVEL THREE.
I AM.
IT.
LEVEL THREE DRIVING A SYSTEMS
NEED TO HAVE A DRIVER IN THE
VEHICLE.
WE THIS IS A.
CONDITIONAL AUTOMATION THAT IS
DESIGNED WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THE HUMAN DRIVER A MAY HAVE
TO INTERVENE.
JEWISH SINCE WE THINK AS
INSURERS.
WITH THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH A NUMBER
OF STAKEHOLDERS IS THIS
DISCUSSION CONTINUES. WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE DMV.
AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ROSEMARY.
KEVIN FRASER AND.
CONVENE BETTER SAKE YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE INVITATION TO TESTIFYING
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THE CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN DOING.
TO IMPROVE SAFETY AND
CALIFORNIA THROUGH VARIOUS.
PROVEN.
MEANS SUCH AS GRADUATED
LICENSING AND ADDRESSING
DISTRACTED DRIVING AND IMPAIRED
DRIVING THAT HAS HAVE REALLY OF
A POSITIVE IMPACT IN OUR STATE.
AND.
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE
TESTIFYING WITH OUR FRIENDS IN
THE TEAMSTERS AND WE SHARE THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT. THE IMPACT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON.
.
JOBS AND DRIVERS WHO RELY ON TO
DO THE DRIVING UNDER DEVELOPED A
LOT OF EXPERTISE AND WE HAVE A
REGULATORY REGIME IN PLACE.
SO THAT THEY ARE SUBJECT TO A
LOT OF REGULATION AND HAVE TO
GET SPECIAL LICENSES AND SO ON
DEPENDING ON WHAT THEIR DRIVING.
AND WE'VE WORK IN COALITIONS
WITH.
ENTITIES IN NEW IN. WASHINGTON
DC.
INTERPOSING EFFORTS THAT ARE
ONGOING THAT WOULD ALLOW
TEENAGERS TO TRY.
TRUCKS.
HONOR FOR HIGHWAYS BIG RIGS.
CARS WORKS ON THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL ON A WHOLE HOST OF
AUTO SAFETY ISSUES. AND WERE
PART OF A COALITION OF SAFETY
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
BICYCLE LUIS ORGANIZATIONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS OF.
ARE. ACTIVE IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SPHERE THEIR OPPOSING THE
AV START ACT THAT IS IN DC WERE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR
FEINSTEIN AND SENATOR HARRIS IS
ROLE. IN TAPPING THE BRAKES ON
THAT LEGISLATION IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS ONE OF THEM
BEING THAT WOULD PREEMPT STATE
LAW.
AND IT WOULD CREATE A REGULATORY
VACUUM WHERE THERE ARE NO NEW
FEDERAL MOTOR VEHICLE SAFETY
STANDARDS IN PLACE THERE IS
SPECIFIC TO THE NEW TECHNOLOGY.
WHILE OPENING THE FLOODGATES FOR
THE VEHICLES NOT ONLY TO BE.
DEVELOPED AND TESTED BUT
ACTUALLY TO BE SOLD CONSUMERS.
AND I THINK THAT BOOK THE.
CRASHES THAT ARE OCCURRING RIGHT
NOW OR UNFORTUNATELY VERY TRAGIC
EVIDENCE THAT WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL. ARM AND NOT.
LEAPT INTO THIS SPACE
PREMATURELY.
AND I WOULD QUOTE FROM OF
TESTIMONY BY THE PRESIDENT OF
ADVOCATES FOR HIGHWAY AND AUTO
SAFETY WHOSE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
INCLUDES LEAVING HEALTH AND
SAFETY ADVOCATES AND
REPRESENTATIVES. OF THE NATION'S
LEADING AUTO INSURANCE COMPANIES.
THAT THE PROCESS CREATED IN THE
AB START ACT WOULD ALLOW
UNTESTED AND UNPROVEN.
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO BE SOLD
TO THE PUBLIC WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE INDEPENDENT OR
GOVERNMENTAL INSIGHT TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY PROTECTIONS. BOTH TO
THOSE IN THE A VIEWS AND THOSE
SHARING THE ROADS WITH THEM.
.
THE AV START ACT TAKES A WRONG
TURN BY ALLOWING FOR THE SALE OF
POTENTIALLY MILLIONS OF
ECONOMISTS VEHICLES TO THE
PUBLIC. WITHOUT MINIMUM SAFETY
STANDARDS
WITHOUT NECESSARY CONSUMER
INFORMATION SO THAT THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS OUR CAPABILITIES AND
LIMITATIONS. AND WITHOUT
CYBERSECURITY STANDARDS TO
PROTECT AGAINST HACKERS.
ACCORDING TO PATRICK LYNN WHO IS
DIRECTOR OF THE ETHICS IN
EMERGING SCIENCE IS GROUP A
CALIFORNIA POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY SELF DRIVING CARS MAY
ENABLE NEW CRIMES WE CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE.
TODAY SO WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
IT'S PREMATURE TO ALLOW THE
VEHICLES TO BE SOLD TO THE
PUBLIC BEFORE THESE PROTECTIONS
ARE IN PLACE. THEY REALLY SHOULD
HAPPEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
PROMULGATE THE RULES
SO THAT THESE VEHICLES ARE
RESISTANT TO HACKING.
AND WE ALSO ADVOCATE THAT THE
VEHICLES SHOULD HAVE TO PASS A
DRIVER'S TEST.
IF YOU ARE I ARE GETTING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE WE NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE CAN OPERATE
SAFELY ON THE ROAD VARIOUS
CONDITIONS.
THESE VEHICLES SHOULD HAVE TO DO
THE SAME.
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF THE VEHICLES
THAT ARE OUT THERE CAN'T REALLY
SEE TO GO SAFELY IN CONDITIONS
SUCH AS YOU KNOW OR FOG OR HEAVY
RAINS OR DENSE SMOKE.
WORK IF THEY GO OVER A STEEP
HILL WHAT THEY SEE IS SCOTT.
SO.
THEIR REAL LIMITATIONS TO WHERE
THEY CAN BE DRIVEN SAFELY. AND
THE PUBLIC IS VERY CONFUSED IN
FACT THEIR NEWS REPORTS AND SAY
THAT ELAINE CHAO WHO IS A
SECRETARY TRANSPORTATION IS SAID
SHE HERSELF IS VERY CONFUSED.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY THERE ARE
SEMI AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES THAT
ARE BEING SOLD TO THE PUBLIC
WHERE THEIR. UNCERTAIN WHAT THEY
CAN EXPECT THE VEHICLE TO DO TO
KEEP THEM SAFE AND WHAT ROLE
THEY NEED TO APPLY. THERE'S A
LOT OF DATA AVAILABLE THAT SHOWS
THAT WHEN PEOPLE.
M. GOOGLE COULD I BELIEVE CAN
CONFIRM THIS GOOGLE IN WAY MO
THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN SEMI
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES THEY TEND TO
BE LULLED INTO A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY. AND THROWN ZONE OUT.
AND WE'RE QUESTIONING THE WISDOM
OF ALLOWING THOSE VEHICLES TO BE
SOLD TO THE PUBLIC.
BECAUSE OF THE.
THEY THE FACT THAT.
.
THE VEHICLES.
CAN'T BE RELIED ON TO OPERATE
SAFELY. AT ALL TIMES AND IT'S
CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE THEY KNOW
WHEN THEY NEED TO TAKE THE WHEEL.
AND IT'S ALSO UNREALISTIC TO
EXPECT SOMEONE WHO HASN'T BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION. TO BE ABLE TO
PAY ATTENTION AND SAFELY
NAVIGATE IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION FOR INSTANCE IF THE
VEHICLE THIS ENGAGES WHEN IT
APPROACH IS A CONSTRUCTION ZONE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DISENGAGEMENT REPORTS AND WE
APPLAUD THE DMV FOR REQUIRING
THOSE AND ALSO REQUIRING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHEN THE
VEHICLES DISENGAGED. A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN THEY DISENGAGE IT IS.
IN CONSTRUCTION ZONES.
WHEN.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR STATE WORKERS
OR OTHER WORKERS MAY BE. IN
HARM'S WAY.
AND I WOULD.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY LIKE TO
MENTION THAT.
.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HEARD.
FROM TESLA THAT.
.
PUTTING AUTOPILOT IN THEIR
VEHICLES REDUCE CRASHES WHERE
THEY ARE AIRBAGS DEPLOYED BY
FORTY.
SENT AND THAT HAS BEEN QUESTION
FOR A LONG TIME NOW THERE'S NEW
REASON TO BE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
THAT FIGURE AS ENCOURAGING IS IT
IS.
.
WHEN ADVOCATES FOR HIGHWAY AND
AUTO SAFETY EXAMINED THE FIGURE
WHAT THEY REPORTED IN THEIR
LETTER TO THE CHAIR OF THE
NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
BOARD WHICH IS A SISTER AGENCY
WITH THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY
TRAFFIC SAFETY ADMINISTRATION.
UNDER THE US DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
THEY REPORTED THAT THE NHTSA
REPORT MAKES A STATEMENT THEY
CRASH
RATES FOR TESLA VEHICLES DROPPED
AFTER THE INSTALLATION OF AUTO
PILOT.
THIS IS AN UNPROVEN AND
UNSUPPORTED CONCLUSION BECAUSE
IN THE SAME SECTION OF THE
REPORT THE AGENCY ADMITS THAT
THE SAFETY IMPROVEMENT. IS NOT
RELATED TO ACTUAL AUTOPILOT USE.
THE FACT IS THAT THIS COMPARISON
IN NO WAY PROVES THAT AUTOPILOT
REDUCES CRASHES.
DOCTOR NEEDY KALRA WHOSE CO
DIRECTOR SENIOR INFORMATION
SCIENTISTS OF THE RAND CENTER
FOR A JUST DECISION MAKING
UNCERTAINTY. ALSO NOTICED THIS
MISLEADING ANALYSIS IN HER
TESTIMONY OFFERED LAST FEBRUARY.
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN BEFORE THE
HOUSE ENERGY AND COMMERCE
COMMITTEE THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
DIGITAL COMMERCE AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
DOCTOR KALRA STATED THAT THE
NHTSA FOUND THE TESLA VEHICLES
EQUIPPED WITH AUTO PILOT WERE
INVOLVED IN FORTY PERCENT FEER
CRASHES IN WHICH AIRBAGS
DEPLOYED. THAN PRE AUTOPILOT
TESLA VEHICLES HOWEVER THE
INTEREST
BEST OCCASION REPORTS NEITHER IS
A STATISTICAL SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS DIFFERENCE NORTHERN NUMBER
OF MILES DRIVE DRIVEN BY EACH
GROUP OF VEHICLES. FROM WHICH
STATISTICAL SIGNIFICANCE CAN BE
COMPUTED.
IF THEREFORE NOT POSSIBLE THE
DETERMINING CONCLUDE FROM THIS
EVIDENCE WHETHER TESLA VEHICLES
WITH AUTO PILOT. ARE INDEED
SAVORED THEN GOES WITHOUT.
AND RECENTLY MAY FOURTH OF THIS
YEAR NHTSA.
INFORMANT REUTERS AND OTHER
PUBLICATIONS THAT RECOVERING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
THAT NEW IT'S A SAFETY DEFECT
INVESTIGATION ON MODEL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TESLA MODEL S.
AND MODEL X.. DID NOT ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
OF THE TECHNOLOGY.
MR PERFORM THIS CURSORY
COMPARISON OF THE RATES BEFORE
AND AFTER INSTALLATION OF THE
VEHICLE THE DETERMINE WHETHER
MODELS EQUIPPED WITH ARTISTS
DEAR WERE ASSOCIATED WITH HIGHER
CRASH RATES. WHICH
WOULD HAVE INDICATED THAT
FURTHER INVESTIGATION WAS
NECESSARY. AND ACTUALLY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF THIS
TESLA HAD INCLUDED.
AUTOMATIC EMERGENCY BRAKING
WITH VEHICLES THAT ALSO HAD THE.
AUTOPILOT SO. THERE ARE THOSE
AND WHO ARE MORE EXPERT THAN I
WHO THINK THAT THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN A ONE OF THE LEADING
FACTORS. IN.
THEIR ASSESSMENT OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF AUTO PILOT.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD CONCLUDE
AND I WOULD WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SEVERAL
MILLION MOVE OVER TO YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'M SET SHOWN FROM THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
WE'RE A NOT FOR PROFIT
TECHNOLOGY POLICY ORGANIZATION
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ABOUT NINETY STAFF MEMBERS
INCLUDING ATTORNEYS AND
TECHNOLOGY RESEARCHERS AND
OTHERS.
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE WORK ON CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
PRIVACY AND THE TECHNOLOGY
ENVIRONMENT AND TRY TO SAFEGUARD
TECHNOLOGY USERS RIGHTS.
I AM A TECHNOLOGIST AND I TRY TO
HELP MY LEGAL COLLEAGUES
UNDERSTAND DETAILS OF TECHNOLOGY.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TALK ABOUT.
INFORMATION SECURITY
CYBERSECURITY ON AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES SO I HAVE A FEW
THOUGHTS TO OFFER.
FIRST MODERN CARS ARE ALREADY
EXTREMELY HIGHLY COMPUTERIZED.
EVEN THOSE CARS THAT DON'T
INCORPORATE ANY KIND OF
AUTONOMOUS OR SELF DRIVING
CAPABILITY.
THE TREND HAS BEEN TOWARD DRIVE
BY WIRE SYSTEMS.
LIKE FLY BY WIRE IN AIRPLANES
WE'RE TURNING THE WHEEL OR
STEPPING ON THE GAS OR BRICK
PEDALS. MAY NO LONGER PHYSICALLY
ACTIVATE THE CARS MECHANICAL
CYST.
THE COMPUTER IS TOLD THAT THE
DRIVER PERFORMED A PARTICULAR
ACTION.
AND THE COMPUTER DECIDES
AGAIN IN SELF DRIVING OR NON
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES.
WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
ACTION SHOULD?
THIS MEANS THAT IN SOME CARS
COMPUTER SOFTWARE FOR EXAMPLE
DECIDES ON THE CONNECTION
OR LACK OF CONNECTION.
BETWEEN STEPPING ON THE BRAKE
PEDAL AND MECHANICALLY ENGAGING
THE BREAK.
THAT MAKES THE RELIABILITY OF
THAT SOFTWARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
CARS SAFE OPERATION.
BECAUSE MALICIOUS OR DEFECTIVE
SOFTWARE.
DEPLOYED TO A CAR COULD MAKE IT
MALFUNCTIONING TRAFFIC DISABLE
SENSORS.
OR EVEN INVERT SAFETY LOGIC
SO THAT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
ATTEMPTS TO CLOSE CRASHES
INSTEAD OF AVOIDING THEM.
THE MOST DISTURBING SCENARIO
THAT I'VE ENCOUNTERED
IN RELATION TO DELIBERATE
ATTACKS ON AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
HAS TO DO WITH SKILL.
HA AND I THINK MISTER MERCS
ALLUDED TO THIS EARLIER AN
ATTACKER WHO WANTS TO CAUSE
MAYHEM AND FEAR TO TRY TO CAUSE
A VERY LARGE NUMBER OF VEHICLES
TO MALFUNCTION IN THE SAME WAY
AT THE SAME TIME.
SUCH AS INTENTIONALLY CRASHING
INTO PEDESTRIANS.
OF COURSE THERE'S NO REASON TO
ASSUME.
LET THIS KIND OF ATTACK IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD OR EASY TO PULL
OFF.
IT WOULD REQUIRE SUBVERTING THE
WIDE RANGE OF SECURITY CONTROLS
WITHOUT BEING DETECTED.
BUT IF IT COULD BE DONE FOR
VARIOUS REASONS THE CONSEQUENCES
COULD BE. MORE WIDESPREAD AND
MORE FRIGHTENING.
THEN OTHER KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL SABOTAGE DIRECTED
AND ON A TON OF THE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
DEMONSTRATIONS ALREADY THAT
SOFTWARE BASED ATTACKS AGAINST
CAR SAFETY COULD BE PRACTICAL.
THE MOST FAMOUS IS PROBABLY A
TWENTY FIFTEEN DEMONSTRATION.
BY TWO RESEARCHERS WHO SHOWED
THAT THEY COULD REMOTELY
TAKEOVER SOME OF THE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS IN A JEEP CHEROKEE.
WHILE THE VEHICLE WAS BEING
DRIVEN IN A WAY THAT COULD HAVE
CAUSED THE CRASH.
IT'S WORTH REITERATING THAT THE
VEHICLE IN THAT CASE WAS NOT
USING ANY SORT OF DRIVERLESS OR
AUTONOMOUS TECHNOLOGY.
A HUMAN WAS BEHIND THE WHEEL
OPERATING THE VEHICLE.
EVEN SO IT GOES TO SHOW THE
COMPUTERS ARE ALREADY SO
INTEGRAL TO THE CAR'S OPERATION.
DOT THE PRESENCE OF RELIABLE
SOFTWARE COULD LEAD DIRECTLY TO
A SAFETY HAZARD.
AS A RESULT JUST AS WITH OTHER
KINDS OF COMPUTING DEVICES BUT
MAYBE WITH HIGHER STAKES.
SOFTWARE UPDATES AND FIXES NEED
TO BE PERFORMED REGULARLY AND
THE INTEGRITY OF THE SOFTWARE
UPDATES NEEDS TO BE PROTECTED.
UNFORTUNATELY
THE PROSPECT OF MAKING THE
SOFTWARE IN THE VEHICLES NON
UPDATABLE. IN ORDER TO AVOID
MALICIOUS UPDATES.
WOULD BE IN EVEN WORSE SOLUTION
BECAUSE IT WOULD MEAN THAT
EFFECTS COULD BE FIXED.
WHEN THEY'RE DISCOVERED.
ARE AGAIN THIS RISK IS NOT
ENTIRELY SPECIFIC TO SELF
DRIVING CARS
INCREASINGLY MANY OF THE SAME
KINDS OF RISKS ALREADY EXISTING
CURRENT MODELS.
WHERE SAFETY FUNCTIONS ARE
MANAGED BY SOFTWARE THAT NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED OVER TIME AND IS
BEING UPDATED OVER TIME?
MANY OF HIS INCREASES IN RISKS
OUR ESSENTIALLY INCREMENTAL
INCREASES IN RISKS THAT MAY
ALREADY EXIST.
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES MAY
CONTAIN ADDITIONAL SENSORS AND
ADDITIONAL LOGICAL FUNCTIONALITY.
LEADING TO ADDITIONAL COMPLEXITY
WHICH DOES PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVENUES FOR
EXPORTABLE VULNERABILITIES
RELATIVE TO HIGHLY COMPUTERIZED
VEHICLES THAT ARE LESS
AUTONOMOUS.
ALSO AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES MAYBE
MORE RELIANT ON ACCURATE MAP
DATA. AND OTHER KINDS OF LIVE
DATA SERVICES PROVIDED BY
MANUFACTURERS AND THEIR
SUPPLIERS. AND THAT COULD BE
ANOTHER SOURCE OF DISRUPTION.
IF THESE SERVICES ARE INTERFERED
WITH OR DISABLED IN SOME WAY.
WE CAN ENVISION SOME KINDS OF
RISKS THAT ARE MORE SPECIFIC TO
SELF DRIVING CARS.
SUCH AS SO CALLED ADVERSARIAL
EXAMPLES IN COMPUTER VISION.
WHICH ARE IMAGES THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY CRAFTED TO BE
SYSTEMATICALLY MISINTERPRETED.
BY PARTICULAR KIND OF COMPUTER
VISION SYSTEM.
IN GENERAL WE MIGHT THINK OF
COMPUTER SOFTWARE AS MORE
COLORFUL AND READILY MANIPULATED.
THAN HUMAN BEINGS.
BUT OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE ALSO
EXTREMELY IN PERFECT AND PRONE
TO BIAS ERROR IN THIS BEHAVIOR.
AND VULNERABLE TO THINGS LIKE
OPTICAL ILLUSIONS.
AND JUST BECOMING DISORIENTED.
IT SEEMS FAIR TO SAY THAT HUMANS
AND MACHINES CAN BE MANIPULATED
OR LEAD TO MISBEHAVE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS FROM ONE ANOTHER.
AS MANY OBSERVERS HAVE NOTED
COMPUTERS DON'T HAVE TO BE
AFFECTED BY FATIGUE OR EMOTION.
OR INTOXICANTS THEY DON'T DRIVE
DRUNK THEY DON'T GET ANGRY THEY
DON'T FALL ASLEEP.
THEY USUALLY CAN'T BE DISTRACTED.
AND THEIR SENSORS MAY BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION IN CONDITIONS WHERE
HUMAN SENSES WOULD BE STARTED.
AND VICE VERSA.
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE MANUFACTURES
EXPERTS AND OTHER RESEARCHERS
NOT AFFILIATED WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS
ARE ALSO PRODUCTIVELY EXPLORING
THE TOPIC OF AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
CYBERSECURITY.
FOR EXAMPLE ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
HAVE FOUND IMPORTANT PROBLEMS
AND RISKS AS HAVE INDEPENDENT
GROUPS. THIS RESEARCH HELPS US
TO UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT WHAT'S
POSSIBLE AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
BUT SECURITY RESEARCHERS WHO
COME TO OUR ORGANIZATION FOR
LEGAL ADVICE.
OFTEN WORRY THAT THEIR WORK MAY
EXPOSE THEM TO LIABILITY OR
LITIGATION.
FOR INSTANCE FROM MANUFACTURERS
WHO MIGHT FEAR EMBARRASSMENT
WHEN PROBLEMS ARE REVEALED.
SO PROTECTING RESEARCHERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN DO
THEIR JOB IS OF TREMENDOUS
THERE MANY GOVERNMENT AND
INDUSTRY ENTITIES WORKING IN THE
FIELD OF VEHICULAR CYBERSECURITY.
INCLUDING NHTSA AND IT IS AN
INDUSTRY GROUP CALLED THE AUTO
ISAC.
NEXT THE SAE AND OTHERS.
IT'S REALLY WORTH EMPHASIZING
THAT THE EXISTENCE OF GUIDANCE
AND STANDARDS IN THIS AREA IS
NOT A SILVER BULLET.
BECAUSE A SINGLE SOFTWARE BUGS
CAN BE ENOUGH TO CREATE A MAJOR
SAFETY AND SECURITY RISK.
MANY OF THE STANDARDS RELATED TO
VEHICULAR SECURITY ARE
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT A
RELATIVELY HIGH LEVEL.
AND NOT A LOW LEVEL OF TECHNICAL
DETAILS WERE SOME OF THE BUGS
MAY EXIST ON THE VULNERABILITIES
MAKE THIS.
INFORMATION SECURITY HAS BEEN AN
ENORMOUS CHALLENGE ELSEWHERE IN
IT.
THERE HAS BEEN LOTS OF HACKS
LOTS OF OLDER GOODIES AND OTHER
KINDS OF COMPUTING SYSTEMS.
THAT WE HAVEN'T DEALT WITH VERY
WELL THAT THE COMPUTING
INDUSTRIES HAVE NOT DEALT WITH
VERY WELL. AND OVERALL THIS IS A
RELATIVELY NEW PREOCCUPATION FOR
THE AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY.
SO THE INDIVIDUAL MANUFACTURERS
BEYOND SIMPLY FOLLOWING A
CHECKLIST OR FORMULA. ARE GOING
TO NEED TO GET A LOT OF SPECIFIC
IN HOUSE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE.
IN INFORMATION SECURITY.
MODERN CARS ALSO HAVE EVER
GREATER PRIVACY RISKS BECAUSE OF
THE INFORMATION THEY COLLECT AND
COMMUNICATE.
ABOUT THEIR OCCUPANTS
WHEREABOUTS AND ENVIRONMENTS.
WELL IF THE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
DESIGNS THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT.
INTENDED ENORMOUS NUMBER OF
SENSORS THAT CAN DETECT MORE
ABOUT THESE THINGS
AND ALL OF THEM TEND TO PHONE
HOME TO THEIR MANUFACTURES FOR A
RANGE OF REASONS.
INCLUDING HELPING THE
MANUFACTURE TO DEBUG THE
SOFTWARE.
AND TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW IT
PERFORMS IN PARTICULAR REAL
WORLD SITUATIONS.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
MANUFACTURERS WOULD WANT THAT
INFORMATION FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS.
BUT IT MEANS THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS WILL COME INTO
POSSESSION OF A LOT OF SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE.
WHERE PEOPLE GO WHOM THEY WERE
WITH WHAT HE DID?
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT THEIR HANDLING AND
RETENTION OF THAT DATA.
THERE ALSO RISKS TO PRIVACY
POSSIBLE WHEN VEHICLES ANNOUNCER
BROADCAST THEIR OWN LOCATIONS.
IF YOU EVER SEEN SERVICES LIKE
FLIGHTAWARE FOR TRACKING
AIRPLANES.
THEY'RE USING THE AIRPLANE
EQUIVALENT CALLED THE DSP.
TO LITERALLY TRACK INDIVIDUAL
AIRPLANES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
FROM MOMENT TO MOMENT.
WE WOULDN'T BE THRILLED TO SEE A
CAR VERSION. OF THE FLIGHT AWARE
SERVICE TO LET YOU LOOK UP THE
WHEREABOUTS OF SOMEONE'S
PARTICULAR CAR.
YEP TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THAT COULD
BE A PRIVACY INFRINGING
CONSEQUENCE OF SOME DESIGNS FOR
LIKE WIRELESS LOCATION BROADCAST.
FOR THAT REASON WE COMMENTED
LAST YEAR ON THE NHTSA VEHICLE
TO VEHICLE OR FEET OF THE
PROPOSAL.
A PROPOSED REGULATORY MANDATE
FOR VEHICLE TO VEHICLE
COMMUNICATIONS.
pFUTURE SAFETY APPLICATIONS FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
WE ARGUED THAT THE PROPOSAL WAS
AN OBSOLETE AND PRIVACY INVASIVE
TECHNOLOGY. THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY ALLOW ANYONE TO
MONITOR A VEHICLE BY RECEIVING
ITS RADIO SIGNALS.
BECAUSE INDIVIDUAL CARS WOULD
EFFECTIVELY BROADCAST THERE ON
THE PETITIONS.
THE COMPARATIVELY SMALL NUMBER
OF IDENTITIES PER CAR.
THIS REGULATION HASN'T BEEN
ADOPTED SO FAR BUT SEVERAL
AUTOMAKERS ARE VOLUNTARILY
IMPLEMENTING TELEMETRY AND
VEHICLE TO VEHICLE
COMMUNICATIONS.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS
OF THOSE DATA FLOWS.
FOR SAFETY REASONS
WE ALSO NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
CAR NEWS THAT A CLAIM TO
POSITION REPORT IS REALLY FROM
ANOTHER
CAR.
AND NOT FROM SOMEONE PRETENDING
TO BE A CAR AND SAYING HEY I'M
IN YOUR WAY.
IF MEMBERS ARE SAFER INTERESTED
IN THIS TOPIC THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF READING YOU CAN DO AND.
PEOPLE WITH INTEREST
THOUGHTS IN THIS AREA.
INCLUDING SOME OF THE FEDERAL
REGULATORS THE GAO RESEARCHERS
OF WHO PUT OUT A REPORT TWO
YEARS AGO ON VEHICULAR
CYBERSECURITY.
AND THE SECURITY ENGINEERS AT
THE INDIVIDUAL AUTOMAKERS AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE IN THE FUTURE.
GETTING SOME ENGINEERS IN HERE
AS WELL AS.
LAWYERS AND LOBBYISTS BECAUSE
THE ENGINEERS WILL HAVE A LOT OF
INTERESTING HANDS ON EXPERIENCE.
.
A BOARD MEMBER OF OUR OWN
ORGANIZATION BRAD TEMPLETON HAS
DONE A LOT OF CONSULTING IN THIS
AREA AND HAS A VERY INTERESTING
AND THOROUGH WEBSITE.
ON THE TOPIC AND OF COURSE
SECURITY RESEARCHERS OUTSIDE OF
INDUSTRY LIKE ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS IN THE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE A LOT OF HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE ON THE SECURITY TOPIC.
IF WE CAN BE OF ANY HELP IN
FINDING SPECIALISTS IN THIS AREA
YOU'D BE.
THRILLED TO AND.
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE I'LL ALSO
BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IT'S ABOUT A REAL PAPER.
I THOUGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SET THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE HIGH I KNOW ORGANIZED
LABOR DISCUSSION LIKE THIS IS
SORT OF LIKE HAVING YOUR CRAZY
HAND IN THE ROOM OR SOMETHING.
BECAUSE THE THOUGHT IS THAT ALL
WE CARE ABOUT IS OUR JOBS COM AT
ANTIQUATED CONCEPT TOO MANY OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM FRANKLY.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT WE DO.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW SOMETHING ELSE.
OUR MEMBERS DRIVE THESE VEHICLES
EVERYDAY
DAY IN AND DAY OUT THEY KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE OF
MOTOR VEHICLES THAN ANYBODY
THERE S..
THEY KNOW THINGS THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS DATE DON'T KNOW
THEY KNOW A LOT.
AND THEY KNOW A LOT ABOUT SAFETY
IN THEIR VERY CONCERNED WITH
MAJOR ISSUES.
WITH THE TESTING AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES WERE NOT HOSTILE TO
CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY THEY
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME THAT
WOULDN'T BE A TEAMSTERS UNION IF
HORSES DIDN'T BECOME TRY.
SO THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE BUT
THERE IS AN ISSUE ABOUT SAFETY.
AND THERE IS A SENSE THAT WE
HAVE.
THAT THE PACE OF CHANGE IS SO
BASS.
THAT POLICYMAKERS ARE JUST NOT.
ABLE TO RESPOND.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
AND SO.
THEY'RE NOT
IN LEGISLATURE'S
AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
ARE SORT OF.
ABANDONING THE FIELD IN A
CERTAIN WAY AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT FIRST EMPLOYEE
AND SAFETY TESTING STANDARDS.
WHAT IS OUR SUCCESSFUL TEST OF
AN AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES?
WHAT IS THE STANDARD
WHEN DO THEY MEET THE STANDARD?
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO'S
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY DO THEY
GET TO KILL SOMEONE IS IT
SUCCESSFUL.
SOMEONE DIES EVERY MILLION MILES
TWO MILLION MILES.
EVER ARE THEY ALLOWED EVER TO DO
THAT I WOULD POSIT.
THERE WERE GONNA GO TO FULLY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES THEY SHOULD
NEVER KILL PEOPLE.
ON.
WHAT ARE THEIR STANDARDS
THAT WERE ACTUALLY DOING THE
TESTING ANOTHER WORDS ARE WE
TESTING THESE VEHICLES UNDER THE
REAL CONDITIONS OF OWNERSHIP?
THAT IS TO SAY ARE WE GONNA LET
THE CAR THE TIRES GO BALD ARE
PEOPLE GONNA FORGET TO MAINTAIN
THEM.
OR A WHAT IS THE REALITY OF THE
TESTING OR IS A MANUFACTURER
BASICALLY FREE TO TEST THE
PRISTINE VEHICLE IN PRISTINE.
CONDITIONS IN WHICH.
THE OIL IS CHANGED AS OFTEN
EXPOSED TO BE CHANGED BUT NOT AS
OFTEN AS IT MIGHT BE CHANGED IN
THE REAL WORLD.
ARE WE WERE REALLY PUSHING THESE
VEHICLES ANOTHER WORDS WHEN
THEY'RE TESTING RIGHT NOW FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN THEY'RE DRIVING
THESE VEHICLES AROUND SAN
FRANCISCO IS SOMEBODY PAID TO
TRY TO HACK INTO ON EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND SEE IF THEY CAN. BREAK
THEIR CYBERSECURITY.
WHAT WHAT WHAT? OBJECTS ARE YOU
THROWING IN FRONT OF THEM TO
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T RUN OVER
THEM ANOTHER WORDS.
SAFETY IS USUALLY A MARGIN OF
SAFETY BEYOND OF THEIR NORMAL WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MEASUREMENT FOR
ANY OF THAT AND YOU KURT THE DMV
PROPERLY SAY. WHAT WORLD WILL
JUST?
YOU KNOW APPROVE THESE THINGS
FOR TESTING IN CALIFORNIA OR
DEPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECIDES.
BOMB IT'S OKAY EXCEPT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS IN
FIGURING THIS OUT AT ALL.
NOW.
HE THE LEGISLATURE MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE YOU GUYS SAID OR DUBBED.
DMV SAID WELL WE'RE NOT READY TO
TEST COMMERCIAL VEHICLES THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY PASSED
TWO BILLS.
TO ALLOW THE TESTING OF BUSES.
ON HIGHWAYS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE NO STEERING WHEEL.
ON THAT HAVE NO BREAK.
AND ARE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE ON
THEM THEY'RE GONNA DOT THERE
SUPPOSED TO BE THIS FIRST MILE
LAST MILE THING THAT GOES TWELVE
MILES AN HOUR. THE ENTITY THAT
IS IN CHARGE OF THE TESTING IS A
TRANSIT AGENCY. PEOPLE WITH
BASICALLY NO EXPERTISE ON HOW
YOU TEST
VEHICLES FOR SAFETY THAT'S NOT
WHAT THEY DO THEY BUY VEHICLES
ARE ALREADY APPROVED FOR TESTING.
AND BEING CONDUCTED BY THE
MANUFACTURER WITH THEM WITH THAT
WITH ECONOMIC INTEREST IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE TESTING ALL ALONG
WITH THE TRANSIT AGENCY WHO DOES
A PRESS RELEASE SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO BE THE CENTER OF THE
FUTURE. OF AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
THAT'S NOT WHO SHOULD BE TESTING
THESE THINGS SKEPTICS SHOULD BE
TESTING THE SEX
NOT PEOPLE WHO HAVE ANNOUNCED
THEIR THAT THEY'RE IN LOVE WITH
THE WHOLE THING. AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE AT THE CENTER UP
SOME FUTURE WORLD OF GOVERNMENT
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN ADVANCE OF
THE TESTING.
SO THAT'S ALL HOLE PUT NUMBER OF
THE ISSUES THAT THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN DEALT WITH THAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO GET INTO. I
THINK YOU FOLKS NEED TO REALLY
WAY INTO THIS.
SECONDLY.
AND I ALLUDED TO THIS.
WORST WHAT'S THE REAL
TRANSPARENCY HERE
WHAT IS STOP PUBLIC GET
TEN NO.
ABOUT THESE WOULD DO WE GET TO
KNOW EVERY COMPETE COMPUTER
FAILURE.
DO WE GET TO KNOW.
.
HOW OFTEN THERE'S?
UP POTENTIAL NEAR MESS I MEAN I
WHO KNOW WHO I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE REALLY KNOW I
KNOW THAT THEY RELEASE WHEN
THERE'S AN ACCIDENT. WHEN
THERE'S AN INCIDENT BUT HEY
WE'VE ALL DRIVEN CARS THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT MORE MAYBE ALMOST
SORDID INCIDENTS.
THAT HAPPENED
WITH VEHICLES AND AS LONG AS
PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE DRIVING
VEHICLES AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SHARING THE ROAD WITH FULLY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES THERE'S
GOING TO BE A COLLISION. OF
TALENTS
AND LESS THAN COUNTS JUST AS THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT INDICATED.
CARS AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES MAY BE
BETTER AT SOME THINGS AND PEOPLE
MAY BE BETTER AT OTHER THINGS.
AND THAT MADE NOT BE SOMETHING
THAT THE A COMPUTER WELL ALL
WILL BE ABLE TO OVERCOME.
AND AND SO THAT'S AN ISSUE WHAT
DO WE KNOW.
AND WHEN ARE WE GOING TO KNOW IT
AND LASTLY AND THIS IS A CLASSIC
AREA OF LEGISLATIVE. ACTIVITY.
WHAT IS REALLY GOING ON HERE IN
THE LIABILITY INSURANCE MARKET
RELATED TO THIS?
WHAT DO ARE WE ALL SUPPOSED TO
BUY?
AUTO INSURANCE.
ON AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE.
IN WHICH WE DON'T OPERATE IT.
WHEN THE RISK OF THE INSURANCE
IS SUPPOSED TO BE ENSURING US
AGAINST OUR NEGLIGENCE.
IS THAT FAIR.
OR SHOULD ALL THIS BE. A
WARRANTY OF THE MANUFACTURER
SHOULD IF BIG CANDLES OF FULLY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE WHY AREN'T
THEY A HUNDRED PERCENT LIABLE.
STRICTLY LIABLE IN TORT FOR ANY
ACCIDENT THAT OCCURS IT'S NOT
MONEY DRIVING ERROR.
AYE SHOULD BE PAYING INSURANCE
FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
ATTRIBUTABLE TO ME.
NOT TO A FAILURE OF THE
MANUFACTURE.
NONE AND SO THAT IS AN AREA THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REALLY OUGHT TO
BE LOOKING AT.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THESE COMPANIES.
SAYING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
.
DEPLOYING THESE VEHICLES AS SOON
AS THEY CAN.
AND THAT COULD BE.
WHAT WITHIN A YEAR TO YEAR TOP
WHEN ARE THEY ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE DOING IT?
AND WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN WE
HAVEN'T EVEN LOOKED AT THESE
ISSUES.
SO.
HOME YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT OLD
STATEMENT.
YOU KNOW FOOLS RUSH IN WHERE
ANGELS DARE TO TREAD AND I THINK
IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT.
IT'S BEEN SAID TODAY BY
EVERYBODY ON THIS PANEL AND
EVERYBODY ON THE PANEL BEFORE.
YOU KNOW A A A A A TRUER
STATEMENT WAS NEVER MADE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BRODER TOLD USE
GOOD.
GLAZER JONES CAN GET RID.
MISTER BERMAN HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL WELL
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH IN AND I
APOLOGIZE AFTER THE BRIEF
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO FOR A PREP
CALL FOR.
THOMAS VEHICLE PENAL I'M
SERVING ON THE MORROW.
BUT I THINK IT'S SOME VERY GOOD
QUESTIONS IN ISSUES WERE RAISED.
AND I WISH I'M GONNA TRY TO
MAKE IT BACK. TO HEAR FROM THE.
FROM THE THIRD PANEL HOPEFULLY
THEY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I MEAN THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS. ABOUT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND I THINK.
THERE ARE THRESHOLD QUESTIONS
ONE IS ARE THEY GONNA BE GOOD
FOR SOCIETY OR ARE THEY GONNA BE
THAT NEXT STEP OF THE APOCALYPSE.
ON AND WHAT YOU GET PAST THAT IF
YOU CAN GET PAST THAT THEN THERE
ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS AS TO HOW
YOU DEPLOY IT HOW YOU TO PLAY IT
SAFELY. I GIVE MY FIRST HEAD X.
TALKING TO THOMAS VEHICLES FOR
YEARS AGO.
AND AND. TALKED TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE IT IN PREP FOR FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER THE TALK WHO
HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
CYBERSECURITY I MEAN ABOUT
HACKING.
ABOUT PRIVACY ABOUT WE NEED TO
COME UP IN AND CREATE A
REGULATORY AND INSURANCE
FRAMEWORK AND HOW THAT'S GONNA.
AGO WHEN ALL I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR
MY FRIEND MR BROAD.
AS YOU KNOW EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THAT
BECAUSE LAST YEAR WHEN I HAD A
BILL ON TRYING TO CREATE A
TESTING PROGRAM FOR A THOMAS
FREIGHT. ó IT WAS OPPOSED
VEHEMENTLY BY MY FRIEND MISTER
BROAD.
AS WELL AS BY THE TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY SO I FOUND MYSELF IN
THIS AWESOME SITUATION WHERE
EVERYONE HATED MY.
BUT BUT I DO THINK IT'S A ROLE
THAT WE NEED TO PLAY I THINK WE
NEED PARTNERS
FROM ALL SIDES TO PARTICIPATE
CONSTRUCTIVELY IN THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND AND YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF
FOLKS TALK ABOUT SAFETY AND AND
A.
IT BROUGHT UP THE QUESTION.
YEAH I'M VERY YOU MENTIONED YOU
KNOW WHAT'S OF THE SAFETY
STANDARD BE AND IF IT TOO IF
YOU'RE FULLY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
SHOULD THERE BE NO DEATHS.
ALRIGHT WELL CURRENTLY WE HAVE
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND DEATHS BY
AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT EVERY YEAR
IN IN THE UNITED STATES SO
THAT'S THE STATE THAT'S.
KIND OF.
THE.
THE BASELINE IF YOU WILL
AND AND SO THIRTY FOR THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND WE'VE ACCEPTED
THAT IS THAT'S OKAY.
IT'S OKAY FOR THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO DIE EVERY
YEAR BECAUSE PEOPLE MAKE
MISTAKES AND CRASH INTO EACH
OTHER.
AND.
SO IS IS A LIFE THAT'S TAKING IN
BECAUSE OVER HUMAN ACCIDENT
WORTH LAST THEN A LIFE THAT
WOULD BE TAKEN BY THE THEN
ACCIDENT FROM TECHNOLOGY.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SAY
THAT THAT IF ONE ACCIDENT YEAH I
MEAN OF ONE PERSON DIES FROM A
THOMAS VEHICLES THAT'S TOO MUCH
OR WHAT'S THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
BECAUSE THAT WAY TOO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT AND SO YOU KNOW
HOW CAN WE. ARE ON AYE AND AND
THEN I I AM. TOTALLY AGREE WE
NEED TO BE COGNIZANT.
OF THE IMPACT IT'S GOING TO HAVE
ON JOBS WE NEED TO AND AND THE
TEAMSTERS AND I ACTUALLY WORK
TOGETHER A WITH A TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY IN MY DISTRICT.
ON ON.
PLATOONING TECHNOLOGY IN TRUCKS
AND I THOUGHT WE HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION AND WAS REALLY GLAD
YEAH THERE WERE ABLE TO DO THAT
TO DEPLOY TECHNOLOGY BUT NOT
IMPACT JOBS.
AND SO THERE NEED TO BE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ALSO BUT.
YOU KNOW LET'S LET'S KEEP
THINGS IN PERSPECTIVE.
AND AND FOR ME.
YOU KNOW IT YOU THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE DYING EVERY YEAR
IS WAY TOO MUCH.
A AND I DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO
DEPLOY TECHNOLOGY VERY CAREFULLY.
AYE AYE SAID THIS FOUR YEARS
AGO THAT.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO BE
READY WAY BEFORE WHAT WAY
EARLIER THAN WE ARE.
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
DEFINITELY THE CASE.
BUT LET'S LET'S KIND OF YOU
KNOW TRY TO KEEP THE BIG PICTURE
IN MIND WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME THESE ISSUES SO I APOLOGIZE
AFTER RUNNING TO TRY TO MAKE IT
BACK OF THIS VEHICLE CALL. OF
THE THANK YOU AND REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO A LOT MORE
CONVERSATIONS.
HE'S MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER BURN.
A MISTER I KANSEN CHU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IT WAS SO VERY LIVELY
DISCUSSION
AND YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES THIS EVOLVING EVERY
DAY. AND WELL WE CAN'T
ANTICIPATE. THAT DOES SOME DAY
YOU ALL THE TRUCKS ON THE ROAD
WILL BE A YOU KNOW A LOT OF SELF
DRIVING AUTONOMOUS.
AND MY CONCERN WAS TOO GOOD TEN
THOUSAND THOUSANDS HOPE A.
LITTLE TOO SLOW TRUCK DRIVERS
AND AND GO WILL SO I WOULD LIKE
TO. MAYBE.
MISS HER BROW CAN TOUCH LITTLE
BIT ALCOHOL.
SURE WE HOW CAN WE AS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO.
TWO OF THE TO CONSIDER HELPING
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENT.
WORK FORCE SOONER DROPPED THE
TRUCK DRIVERS
TO TRANSITION INTO OTHER
PROFESSIONS.
WELL IT'S PROBABLY. BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THIS HEARING BUT AND
BECAUSE IT'S A BIG TOPIC AND
THAT THAT THE ESTIMATES ARE THAT.
IN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS
DEPENDING ON THE ROLL OUT OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY THAT SOMEWHERE
AROUND TEN MILLION PEOPLE WILL
LOSE THEIR JOBS.
JOHN THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND THEN IN IN MANY OTHER
INDUSTRIES SO THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER DO YOU TRAIN THEM FOR
ANOTHER INDUSTRY.
YOU GIVE THEM SORT OF JOB
TRAINING THAT'S SORT OF THE
TRADITIONAL.
THING STRATEGY.
UPON IT MAY NOT BE A STRATEGY
THAT WORKS.
IF WERE FACING A FUTURE IN WHICH
THERE ARE.
THERE'S NO JOBS TO GO TO IN
OTHER WORDS IF YOU KEEP.
IF THE PACE OF AUTOMATION YOU
KNOW FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY TO NOW IS
LIKE THIS WE MAY HAVE A PACE OF
AUTOMATION THAT GOES LIKE THIS.
AND WE MAY BE FACING SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT IN OUR
SOCIETY WHICH FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S BUT MAYBE THAT NOT.
FOR THAT NOT THAT FAR IN THE
FUTURE WILL BE FACING WHICH IS.
THE IDEA THAT THERE WILL BE.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE DETACHED PERMANENTLY
FROM THE LABOR MARKET.
AND
THE LOOPHOLE CONCEPT OF THE
LABOR THEORY OF VALUE WILL BE
UNDER CHALLENGE
SO I'D LIKE TO SAY IT'S EASY TO
SAY TRAIN PEOPLE FOR ANOTHER JOB.
BUT THERE MAY NOT BE ANOTHER JOB.
BECAUSE THAT GOES AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ARE NOT THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE AUTOMATION IS OCCURRING
IT'S OCCURRING. EVERYWHERE
ACROSS THE ECONOMY VERY BROADLY
FROM.
YOU KNOW FARMWORKERS TO
RESTAURANTS TO HOTELS TO AIRPORT
MEETS EVERYWHERE
AND WOULD BE NAIVE TO THINK THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW TEACHING IT IT'S
WE NOT NAIVE TO THINK THAT THAT
GENERAL TREND WILL NOT.
MUCH CHANGE IN WE MAY HAVE TO
THINK MUCH IN A MUCH BIGGER WAY
AND WAY MORE CREATIVELY THAN
JUST DRAW JOB TRAINING I I CAN'T
TELL YOU AS I SIT HERE TODAY AND
I I MEAN THAT'S VERY SINCERELY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU AS I SIT HERE
TODAY WHAT THE ANSWER IS TO THAT
PROBLEM.
MIDDLE ONE TRADITIONAL ANSWER
FRANKLY WAS THAT'S HOW THEY WENT
FROM THE SIXTY HOUR WORK WEEK TO
THE FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK DURING
ANOTHER PERIOD OF INTENSE
AUTOMATION AND WHICH THEY SPREAD
THE WORK AROUND.
THAT WAS PART OF IT TO MAKE
PEOPLE WORK LAST TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE AND TO SHORTEN THE
WORK WEEK AND IN GERMANY NOW
THERE ARE ON THIS THE. BIG
INDUSTRIAL MANUFACTURING
EMPLOYERS AND THEIR UNIONS
BECAUSE THEY DO SECTOR
BARGAINING. JUST AGREED TO I
BELIEVE IT'S THE TWENTY EIGHT
HOUR WORK WEEK.
AS A FULL AS A FULL TIME JOB.
BECAUSE OF THE ADVANCE OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR THIS PURPOSE AND
WHILE THAT MIGHT SOUND.
WAY OUT THERE.
IT MAYBE IT ISN'T MAYBE WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO IS SPREAD WORK TO THE
ENTIRE POPULATION AS THE NUMBER
LITERALLY THE NUMBER OF JOBS TO
BE PERFORMED BY HUMAN.
SO I I WISH I HAD A PAT ANSWER
FOR YOU.
BUT I DON'T.
FONG.
UP I.
I APPRECIATE THE PANEL I THINK
YOU.
PROVIDED SOME VERY LARGE.
CONCEPTUAL CONCEPTS THAT WE
HAVE TO DIGEST IN AND.
REPREHENSIBLE AND I GUESS WE
CAN MAKE A DRILL DOWN WITH AT
LEAST WITH THE INSURANCE HAVE
FOLKS. WHAT CRITERIA ARE YOU
GUYS YOU UTILIZING OR HAVE
DEVELOPED TO AND? IN TERMS OF
ENSURING AUTOMATED.
VEHICLES ON THE ROADS
IF YOU HAVE THAT.
I MEAN I THINK THAT THAT THAT IS
PART OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
UNDERSTANDING THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF WE CERTAINLY ARE IT IT'S
IT MIGHT ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
ARE BOTH COMMERCIAL INSURERS AND
PERSONAL INSURANCE I THINK ONCE
WE SEE PUBLIC DEPLOYMENT. OF
THESE IN OUR ARE THERE ACTUALLY
SOLD ON TO INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL
SEE THAT INVOLVING THINK WE SEE
THAT COMING AND AND WE DON'T
KNOW RIGHT NOW
IS THE ANSWER.
WERE WERE. OBSERVING.
THE TEST JUST LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THE PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE IT
THINK MISTER BROAD? BROUGHT UP
BUT THE STINK WHITE WE COULD
DEEP DIVE I THINK IN JUST THE
LIABILITY ISSUES.
AND HOW THAT WORKS OUT WITH ON
SADDAM ITS VEHICLES A. AND MAY
PROBLEMS OUTSIDE THE SCOPE
HEARING TODAY. WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF AND THE
NOW THAT'S GOING TO INTEGRATE
WITH OUR CURRENT TOWARD.
LIABILITY SYSTEM THAT WE USE.
IN THE IN THE BOTH PERSONAL CO
COMMERCIAL AROUND SO I YOU KNOW
THAT THE CRITERIA TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OF I DON'T KNOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT I THINK LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE INTERESTED ON
STAKEHOLDERS.
AS TO THE THE POTENTIAL FOR
THIS TECHNOLOGY WHICH
TO BE CLEAR WERE BULLISH ON AND
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S SOMETHING.
THAT.
KING CAN CREATE MORE STICK IT
EVENTUALLY CAN BECOME AND SAFER
AND MORE EFFICIENT ALWAYS TRAVEL.
IN IN ENTERS OF THE JUST WILL
QUICKLY INTO THIS THE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS OF WHO'S
INVOLVED IN INTERNET THE STATE.
I MEAN THAT YOU'RE MORE MORE
GENERALLY SPEAKING SO I THINK
EVERYBODY'S
WE HEAR FROM CONSUMER ADVOCATES
INSURERS MANUFACTURERS
TECHNOLOGY GROUPS EXCEPT.
OKAY THANK YOU BYE AYE I THINK
BROADLY OUT OF SAY THAT WE WE
ARE GOING TO SOME TYPE OF YOU
KNOW INDEX REVOLUTION THERE'S
GOING TO BE. TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENTS PROBABLY THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN I I DO GOODNESS
BROUGHT THAT.
IN THEN IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
OF THE JUSTICE.
INNOVATIVE IN THE PAST FIFTY.
I THINK WE DO HAVE TO. FIND A
WAY TO PRIORITIZE SAFETY AS
VISIT IN SPECIFICS WITH WITH
AUTOMATED.
VEHICLES AS WELL AS JOBS
INNOVATION AND KILL OUR STATE
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF IT
INNOVATION THAT WE. THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BE LATER ON AND
SO I'M NOT SURE IF WE WILL AS A
LEGISLATURE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T STIFLE INNOVATION
BUT ALSO MAINTAIN.
SET TYPE OF.
ABILITY TO ENSURE THAT.
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY TO TO TO UP TO LIVE
LOOK AT THE STATE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER PHONE CONSUMER
GOODS SETH.
SO DO YOU THINK THE UTOMOTIVE
INDUSTRY IS DOING ENOUGH.
I TO PROTECT ITS VEHICLES FROM
HACKING AT THIS POINT.
SO IT DIFFICULT TO SAY PARTLY
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS IN.
INFORMATION SECURITY.
AND THERE ARE SO MANY ENTIRE
CLASSES OF VULNERABILITIES THAT
ARE STILL BEING DISCOVERED.
.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE WORKING PRETTY HARD ON
IT.
I THINK.
SINCE.
THE FIELD IS SO NEW THERE'S JUST
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY OUT THERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
COLLABORATION WITH INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHERS ON WITH ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS WHO ARE OFTEN PEOPLE
WHOM WE REPRESENT AND GIVE LEGAL
ADVICE TO.
WHO ARE ALSO WORKING IN THIS
AREA AND WHO ARE OFTEN THE ONES
WHO DISCOVER?
SOME OF THE NEW THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO BE WORRYING ABOUT.
I DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO
SUGGEST THAT THE MANUFACTURERS
ARE JUST SORT OF.
FALLING ASLEEP AND.
COMPLETELY IGNORING THE ISSUE IN
FACT THEY'RE WORKING ON IT QUITE
HARD.
THERE'S JUST SORT OF THE
UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS PHENOMENON OF.
IS THAT ENOUGH.
WHAT IS NECESSARY?
SO IS THERE A.
.
POSSIBILITY CREATED A COMPUTER
SYSTEM THOSE.
CRASH PROOF.
SO I THOUGHT IT'S INTERESTING TO
COMPARE WITH THE EXPERIENCE OF.
.
AVIATION.
WHICH HAS HAD AUTONOMOUS.
SOFTWARE CONTROLLED NAVIGATION
FOR A LONG TIME NOW.
AND A LOT OF THE TIME WHEN
YOU'RE ON A COMMERCIAL.
AIRLINE.
THE PILOT IS NOT IN FACT
DIRECTLY INTERACTIVELY
CONTROLLING.
THE MOVEMENT OF THE AIRPLANE
BECAUSE THE AUTO PILOTS ARE VERY
EFFECTIVE.
AND THEY'RE USED A LOT OF THE
TIME.
NOW.
THE.
IF YOU ISSUE INDUSTRY IS VERY
VERY HIGHLY REGULATED. AND
THEY'VE SPENT ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY ON SOFTWARE QUALITY
ASSURANCE.
THAT'S REALLY THE ENVY OF THE
REST OF THE IT WORLD.
AND.
I THINK THERE IS A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER THAT KIND OF LEVEL
OF INVESTMENT.
IN QUALITY ASSURANCE
IS.
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO REACH THAT
LEVEL OF ASSURANCE BECAUSE THEY.
THEY'VE REACHED A VERY
ADMIRABLE SAFETY RECORD
INCLUDING FOR AUTONOMOUS PHASES
OF FLIGHT.
AND THEY'VE REACHED THAT BY
SPENDING A GREAT DEAL OF MONEY
AND A GREAT DEAL OF ENGINEERING
EFFORT ON THAT AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
THAT LEVEL OF ASSURANCE.
IS GOING TO REQUIRE PUTTING
INCOMPARABLE RESOURCES
IN THE AUTOMOTIVE FIELD AS WELL.
HA AND I THINK IT MAY TURN OUT
THAT IT DOES WHICH MAY BE A BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE.
TO PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WHO WERE
USED TO JUST SORT OF SITTING
DOWN AND KNOCKING OUT A COMPUTER
PROGRAM.
NOT TO SUGGEST THAT THAT'S WHAT
THE SELF DRIVING
SOFTWARE IS LIKE.
BUT.
THE AVIATION PEOPLE I MEAN YOU
CAN TALK TO SOME OF THEM.
THEY WRITE FORMAL SPECIFICATIONS
AND THEY HAVE SO MANY FORMAL
PROCESSES AND SO MANY TOOLS.
TO REALLY GET THE BUGS OUT OF
THEIR SOFTWARE.
AT GREAT EXPENSE
HAND IT MAY TURN OUT TO BE THAT
FOR. THAT LEVEL OF RELIABILITY
THAT WE EFFECTIVELY NEED TO GO
THERE WITH THAT KIND OF
METHODOLOGY.
THANK YOU.
SO ROSEMARY.
YOU'VE BEEN SITTING IMPATIENTLY
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL STEPS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE TAKEN TO
ENSURE THE SAFE TESTING.
AUTOMATED.
AUTOMATED OF VEHICLES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
QUESTION CHAIRMAN FRAZIER.
WE HAVE RECOMMENDED SEVERAL
THINGS THAT WE AS A STATE CAN DO.
TO IMPROVE SAFETY AND NUMBER
ONE WOULD BE. TO REQUIRE A
RIGOROUSLY PROVEN TRACK RECORD
OF SAFE OPERATION WITHOUT
DISENGAGEMENT IN ALL KINDS OF
TRAFFIC CONDITIONS IN VARIOUS
WEATHER CONDITIONS. INCLUDING
FOG RAIN HEAVY SMOKE AND SNOW
BECAUSE. EVEN THOUGH IT'S ALMOST
ALWAYS GORGEOUS AND SUNNY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE DO HAVE DIFFERENT WEATHER
PATTERNS AND AND WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE ESPECIALLY WHERE YOU SEE
MORE OF THAT.
BEFORE THE VEHICLES ARE SOLD TO
THE PUBLIC.
AND.
REQUIRING THE AV'S PASS A
DRIVER'S TEST
SHOWING THAT THEY CAN SEE.
OBJECTS IN THE ROAD BEFORE THEM.
INCLUDING STATIONARY OBJECTS OR
OBJECTS THAT ARE MOVING AND
APPARENTLY THERE ARE SOME
VEHICLES THAT ARE BETTER AT THAT
THAN OTHERS. THEY'RE CURRENTLY
BEING SOLD AND PROHIBIT.
SALES OF LEVEL THREE AND FOUR
VEHICLES.
AND I KNOW THERE'S SOME
MANUFACTURERS WHO DIFFER IN
THEIR OPINION OF WHETHER THAT'S
A GOOD IDEA.
BUT SOME MANUFACTURERS I THINK
WOULD AGREE WITH US THAT.
NOT SAFE TO RELY ON HUMAN
DRIVERS NOT TO BECOME DISTRACTED
AND.
TO RELY ON THEM TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THE WHEEL A MOMENT'S NOTICE
AND KNOW WHAT TO DO.
EMERGENCY SITUATION.
AND ESPECIALLY AS THE VEHICLES
BECOME MORE COMMON YOU'RE
DRIVING IS A SKILL TAKES A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE TO BECOME A REALLY
GOOD DRIVER. SO WE ARE CONCERNED
TOO ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN.
PEOPLE LOSE THAT SKILL AND
HAVING DEVELOPED IT ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE OVER
CONTROL.
I'M MANDATE FULL PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE AND REPORTING OF
CRASHES INVOLVING AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
NOT ALLOWING MANUFACTURERS OF
THEIR VEHICLES TO HIDE BEHIND
LIKE FORCED ARBITRATION WHICH IS
A CLOSED FORM.
IN SECRET.
AND ESTABLISH REASONABLE
STANDARDS FOR FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND INSURANCE THE
THRESHOLD IN.
SENATOR PADILLA'S PHIL WAS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M.
NOT SURE BUT I HAVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT THAT WAS. WHAT
WAS IN MY JUST FOR THE TESTING
PHASE? SO FOR GOING TO ALLOW THE
VEHICLES TO BE SOLD IN LARGE
VOLUMES WE WANT TO HAVE ENTITIES
THAT ARE FAR MORE SOLVENT THAN
THAT. IN ONE LIFETIME EXPENSE
FOR HEAD INJURED TEENAGER COST
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SO WE DON'T WANT
TO BE IN A SITUATION WHERE.
MORE.
FLY BY NIGHT.
ENTITIES ARE ENTERING INTO THIS
SPACE AND OFFERING PRODUCTS AND
THEN WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM NOT
BE ABLE TO STAND BEHIND THEM.
AND ALSO PROHIBIT MISLEADING
TERMINOLOGY IN FALSE ADVERTISING
REGARDING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
IT'S
WE BELIEVE IT'S MISLEADING
SOMETIMES IF. PEOPLE. ARE HYPED
BY THE TERMINOLOGY AND THEY
DON'T HAVE REASONABLE
EXPECTATIONS.
AND ALSO TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
NO LOT OF TIMES THE OWNERS
MANUALS ARE ONLY IN ENGLISH.
IF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW?
WHAT IS EXPECTED OF THEM WHAT
THEY CAN EXPECT TO THE VEHICLE
IN ORDER FOR TO OPERATE SAFELY
YOU HAVE TO THINK WE? HAVE A
VERY DIVERSE POPULATION OUR
STATE AND WE WANT ALL OF THEM TO
BE SAFE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO VERY.
.
LOT OF GOOD POINTS.
MULTIPLICITY OPEN APPRECIATE THE.
.
THE THOUGHTFULNESS ABOUT WHAT IS
THE BAR.
SAFETY IN.
I THINK MISTER BERMAN HAD A.
A GREAT.
STATEMENT ABOUT YOU KNOW THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND.
AND WE KNOW THE POTENTIAL OF.
.
SAVING LIVES CAN BE HUGE.
SO DO THE TEAMSTERS HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT LEVELS OF
AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE DRIVER TO
TAKE OVER THE WHEEL UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
WE DON'T.
WITH NO BASICALLY WE DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THAT ALTHOUGH.
NONE.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
OPERATE LOCOMOTIVES.
WHERE YOU GO LONG STRETCHES OF
TIME?
IN WHICH.
THE TRAIN IS KIND OF RUNNING
ITSELF
AND THEN SOMETHING VERY JARRING
CAN HAPPEN.
LIKE A KID CAN RIDE UP ON A BIKE
TOWARDS OF WRITTEN A CROSSING
WAS SOMETHING SUDDENLY CAN
HAPPEN.
AND THEY DO REPORT THAT IN THOSE
SITUATIONS IT'S A GOOD THING
THERE'S A SECOND PERSON IN THAT
LOCOMOTIVE WITH AND THERE'S TWO
IN A FREIGHT LOCOMOTIVE BECAUSE.
IT KEEPS YOU AWAKE AND ALERT AND
WHEN YOU'RE WITH OTHER PEOPLE'S
ANOTHER PERSON SO YOU CAN STAY
AT THOSE CONTROLS. SO THERE ARE
ISSUES.
WHEN THERE'S IN ACTIVITY
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME THAT
PEOPLE'S MINDS BEGIN TO WANDER
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TRAIN
DRIVERS HOW TO OPERATE.
IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
ON I JUST WANNA MAKE SOMETHING
VERY CLEAR THAT THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT.
FULLY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
SOME POINT COULD SAVE LIVES
THE POINT I WAS MAKING IS NOT.
THAT THERE CAN NEVER BE A DEATH
BUT WHAT IS THE STANDARD
IT'S THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE KILLED. ARE THEY
WORKING IF THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE GET KILLED. EVERY YEAR
PROBABLY NOT ARE THEY WORKING IF
TWENTY PEOPLE GET KILLED EVERY
YEAR PROBABLY I MEAN ANOTHER
WORDS I'M JUST SAYING YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A STANDARD OF WHAT.
MEETS THE LEVEL OF SAFETY THAT.
SAFETY EXPERTS THINK IS
REASONABLE. TO REQUIRE NOT.
THAT.
THERE'S PERFECTION ALTHOUGH IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF THEY'RE
FULLY AUTONOMOUS THAT THE HOPE
WOULD BE.
THAT.
IT THERE WOULD BE.
VERY VERY FEW INJURIES AND
DEATHS ON THE HIGHWAY WHICH
WOULD BE AN ENORMOUS BENEFIT TO
SOCIETY SOMEDAY IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S MY ONLY POINT ABOUT THAT.
YEAH I KNOW THAT. THEY'D THROUGH
CALTRANS ANOTHER DEPARTMENTS
TREND TRANSPORTATION.
IT'S CALLED DEATH BY MILE COMEY
DESPERATE MILE WAS IN A CERTAIN.
AREA BEFORE THEY RESPOND HARM TO
MAKE SAFETY CONCERNS IN ON
ROADWAYS SO AGAIN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE. THE PEOPLE
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO YOU
KNOW ESTABLISH.
AGAIN. POINT WELL TAKEN.
AND THE I THINK THAT.
AS YOU HAD MENTIONED.
THAT FOR EVERY.
PROPONENT OF A OF A. OF A PART
OF.
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES THERE SHOULD
BE A CRITIC.
TO BE ABLE TO CRITICIZE IT.
TO THE NTH DEGREE SO THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
BEEN RUN THROUGH ITS PACES.
IT YOU KNOW BUMPY ROADS.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BE PART OF A.
SOMETHING COMING LOOSE.
OF OR WHATEVER SO I MEAN AGAIN
THERE'S THERE'S TESTING IN AND
THEN THERE'S TESTING.
AND SO LOOKING FORWARD TO OF
THIS CONTINUAL PRACTICE JUST AS
WE HAD MENTIONED. THAT YOU
WORKING WITH THE PUBLIC IF
THERE'S A ROLL OUT OF OF THE
TIMES VEHICLES IN THEIR CITIES
THAT THEY'RE PUT ON NOTICE.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE.
SO HOW WOULD THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY YOU CALL UP THE THIRD
PANEL. VARYING GAUGE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL UP
JUST EARLY. HEAD OF POLICY FOR
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES WITH UBER.
RUN MEDFORD DIRECTOR OF SAFETY
FOR A MO.
AND PAUL HILL BERS BALL CHIEF
COUNSEL IN PUBLIC POLICY
DIRECTOR TRANSPORTATION AS A
SERVICE GENERAL MOTORS.
JUSTIN WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD START
WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. INTERFERE
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN EHRLICH AND
THE HEAD OF POLICY FOR. THE THAT
THOMAS VEHICLE PROGRAM AT UBER
BASIN SAM CISCO.
AND I PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A
SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL COMMA HARRIS
ADVISING A TECHNOLOGY PRIVACY
AND SECURITY POLICY.
HG ARE THOMAS UNIT IS A GROUP
WITH THAT WITHIN OVER THAT WAS
STARTED THREE YEARS AGO TO FOCUS
ON VEHICLE AUTOMATION AND HAS
GROWN OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. WITH OFFICES IN
PITTSBURGH SAME CISCO PHOENIX IN
TORONTO.
I WE ARE DEVELOPING TO PRODUCTS
SELF DRIVING CARS AS WELL AS
SELF DRIVING COMMERCIAL VEHICLES.
AT THE SAME TIME HOOVER'S CORE
RIDE SHARING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN TO OVER SIX
MILLION UNIQUE RIDERS AND MANY
MORE ARE EXPERIENCING RIDE
SHARING FOR THE FIRST TIME EVERY
DAY.
OUR MISSION IS TO IMPROVE URBAN
MOBILITY AND MAKE CITIES MORE
LIVABLE AND IMPROVE SAFETY AND
EFFICIENCY OF THE ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION ECOSYSTEM.
AND IN ADDITION TO IS A SELF
DRIVING CARS ARE ALSO DEVELOPING
SELF DRIVING TECHNOLOGY FOR
COMMERCIAL MOTOR VEHICLES TO
GENERATE SIMILAR SAFETY AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS IN THE FREIGHT
INDUSTRY.
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS PARTICULAR
IMPORTANT IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THE PASSENGER SIDE WE BELIEVE
THAT.
SELF DRIVING PASSENGER VEHICLES
ARE VERY WELL SUITED FOR RIDE
SHARE.
OUR OUR VISION IS TO WORK
TOWARDS OUR RIGHTS BUSINESS AND
OUR SELF DRIVING WORK.
TO UNIFY TOWARDS A SHARED
ELECTRIC AUTONOMOUS FUTURE USE
OF VEHICLES.
SHARE USE WILL UNLOCK ALL OF.
THE BENEFITS PROMISED BY LARGE
SCALE DEPLOYMENTS OF BABIES IN
URBAN AREAS NOT JUST IMPROVE
SAFETY OUTCOMES BUT ALSO.
WITH THE RIGHT POLICIES REDUCE
CONGESTION EMISSIONS
REDUCED PARKING DEMAND
UTILIZATION OF TRANSIT ETCETERA.
ARE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION UNIQUE
WRITERS TOOK A SHARED TRIP AND
REPORT.
UBER IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED WITH
A COMBINATION NETWORK HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE TO HELP LEAD
INNOVATION AND SELF DRIVING AND
WE HAVE A STRONG ENGINEERING
GROUP INTERNALLY AS WELL AS
WORKING WITH WORLD CLASS
MANUFACTURING PARTNERS LIKE
VOLVO AND DAIMLER.
WE HAVE A CORE BUSINESS THAT
POSSESSES THE PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE THAT COMES FROM
RUNNING RIDE SHARING AND
DELIVERY SERVICES MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED CITIES AND THE
EXPERIENCE INTELLIGENCE THAT
COMES FROM DOING BILLIONS OF
TRIPS ON THE ROAD. IN MORE THAN
SIXTY COUNTRIES.
AND WE HAVE RECENTLY COMPLETED
OVER FOUR BILLION TRIPS IN THE
WORLD IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE.
THAT EXPERIENCE
THE OF CONNECTING WITH AND
PICKING UP DROPPING OFF
PASSENGERS.
MAY SEEM ON THE MORE
RUDIMENTARY SIDE BUT WE BELIEVE
IT IS ACTUALLY QUITE PIVOTAL.
A TO FUTURE DEPLOYMENT OF AV'S
AND COMPLEX URBAN AREAS.
I BELIEVE THE INNOVATION THE
SPACE CAN ALSO BE GOOD FOR
WORKING PEOPLE NOT JUST IN
PROVIDING MORE RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE TRANSPORTATION.
BUT ALSO. FIND JOB OPPORTUNITIES
AND TO TRANSFORM EXISTING
INDUSTRIES LIKE FREIGHT AND LONG
HAUL TRUCKING AND SHORT HAUL
TRUCKING.
FOR TRUCKING IN PARTICULAR IT
IS ESSENTIAL TO THE US ECONOMY
AND ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION NEARLY
SEVENTY PERCENT OF ALL THE
FREIGHT TONNAGE MOVED IN THE U.
S. IS BY TRUCKS.
SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
ARE EMPLOYED IN JOBS THEIR
RELATED TRUCKINGIN TWENTY
FIFTEEN.
IT IS THE PREDOMINANT MODE OF
FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA MOVING EVERYTHING
FROM MANUFACTURED GOODS
TO RESOURCE EXTRACTION LIKE LOGS
AND SAND TO FOOD AND FARM TO
MARKET PRODUCTS.
IN FACT OVER SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF ALL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA PLANNED EXCLUSIVELY
ON THEIR TRUCKS TO MOVE THEIR
GOODS.
CONSIDERING THE SCALE THE
INDUSTRY AND ITS ROLE IN OUR
STATE WE BELIEVE THAT IMPROVING
SAFETY AND EFFICIENCY OF THE
TRACKING SYSTEM SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED AND WILL GENERATE
IMMENSE.
BENEFITS IN CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND.
AND TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL AS I
MENTIONED WE ARE WORKING ON SELF
DRIVING TRUCKS AS WELL AS UBER
FREIGHT.
WE MISSION SEE AN INDUSTRY.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE PUBLISHED
OUR VISION FOR THE FUTURE OF
TRUCKING.
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALL READ IT
IF YOU ARE INTERESTED IT IS ON
OUR BLOG.
I IT IS WORTH MENTIONING THAT
TODAY UBER FREIGHT A PHONE BASED
BROKERAGE IS ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE MOST PRESSING PAIN POINTS
FOR TRUCK DRIVERS SUCH AS
TRACING TRANSPARENCY. RELIABLE
LOAD BOOKINGS AND FAST PAY.
FREIGHT SERVES MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE THE CORE OF
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA'S HOME
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
TRUCKING COMPANIES MOST OF WHICH
WERE LOCALLY OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND SOME OF THESE ARE HOOVER'S
PARTNERS ALREADY AND ARE BETTING
FITTING FROM OUR INVEST IN THE
INDUSTRY.
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO VOICE THE.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
TRUCKING AUTOMATION ON JOB
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE CERTAINLY DO NOT TAKE THIS
CONCERN LIGHTLY.
AND ACTUALLY WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE IMPACTS AND SO
WE TOOK IT UPON HERSELF TO
CONDUCT AN IN DEPTH ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS.
WORKING WITH SOME ECONOMISTS TO
HELP UNDERSTAND. ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPACT WOULD BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT ARE CONSIDERATIONS OF
OUR BUSINESS MODEL AND OUR
DEPLOYMENT CURVES.
ARE ANNOUNCES RECOGNIZE THAT THE
SELF DRIVING TRUCKS WILL
CERTAINLY CHANGE THE INDUSTRY.
ARE AND IT WILL LEAD TO A SHIFT
FROM LONG HAUL JOBS TO A LOCAL
JOBS.
BUT THAT IT ALSO MIGHT LEAD TO
A GENERATION OF GROWTH IN THE
SHORT HAUL JOB INDUSTRY.
.
AND THE LOCAL TRUCKING SECTOR.
WE PUBLISH ALL THOSE RESULTS AS
WELL AS OPEN SOURCE THE MODEL ON
OUR WEBSITE AND AGAIN ENCOURAGE
ANYONE WHO'S INTERESTED TO TAKE
A LOOK.
FINALLY TURNING TO REGULATORY.
WE APPLAUD THE DMV'S WORK
LEADING A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
OVER MANY YEARS WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS TO PRODUCE FINAL
LIGHT VEHICLE REGULATIONS THAT
PAVE A PATH THE FULL DEPLOYMENT
OF DRIVERLESS PASSENGER CARS.
THE DMV REGULATIONS THAT WENT
INTO EFFECT ON APRIL FIRST
REPRESENT A VERY THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO TESTING AND
DEPLOYMENT AUTONOMOUS CARS.
AND ALONG WITH OTHERS IN THE
INDUSTRY.
WE WERE A HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE
AND SUBMITTED COMMENTS
RECOMMENDING CHANGES
SOME MADE INTO THE FINAL
REGULATIONS BUT OTHERS DO IT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE THE DMV TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW ROSS.
ANY CHANGES TO THOSE RECOMMEND.
REGULATIONS WE. RECOMMEND BE
CONSIDERED CAREFULLY AND AND
USING ALL THE EVIDENCE.
WITH LIGHT VEHICLE RULES
FINALIZE WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DMV AND CHP TURNING TO
DEVELOPMENT OF RULES FOR HEAVY
TRUCKS AND WE PLAN TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROCESS.
THE CPUC RECENTLY RELEASED A
PROPOSED DECISION TO CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWING LIMITED
USE OF SELF DRIVING CARS TO
CARRY PASSENGERS FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHOUT COMPENSATION.
AT THIS DECISION WOULD ALLOW
COMPANIES THAT BOTH THE DMV
PERMIT AND THE CPUC LIVERY
PERMIT TO CARRY PASSENGERS.
BUT WOULD IMPOSE ARRESTS AT AN
ARRAY OF ADDITIONAL HURDLES
DELAYS IN MANDATES AND WOULD NOT
ACCOMMODATE DMV AB DEPLOYMENT
PERMITS.
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSED DECISION.
MIGHT IMPOSE REDUNDANT
REQUIREMENTS AND ACTUALLY LIMIT
THE ABILITIES.
INDUSTRY'S ABILITY TO THE LEFT.
DEVELOPED THE BEST CUSTOMER
SOLUTIONS
AND OTHERWISE UNDERCUT EXISTING
STATE RULES TO AUTHORIZE
ENCOURAGED DEPLOYMENT OF SELF
DRIVING VEHICLES.
SO WE AND OTHERS IN THE INDUSTRY
HAVE URGED THE COMMISSION TO
RESPECT THE DIEM THESE
JURISDICTION OVER A BUREAU
TESTING AND HARMONIZE ITS
PROPOSAL WITH THE IN THE RULES.
WITHOUT DRIVING PASSENGER
SERVICE IN ITS INFANCY WE URGED
THE COMMISSION PROVIDE SIMPLE
GUIDANCE ON OPERATING DMB
PERMITTED AV'S UNDER THE
COMMISSION.
EXISTING RULES.
IN MARCH.
A AND UBER TEST VEHICLE WAS
INVOLVED IN A TRAGIC ACCIDENT
INTENT BAY IN ARIZONA IN WHICH A
PEDESTRIAN ELAINE HERTZBERG WAS
FATALLY INJURED.
OUT WE WERE SHOCKED AND SADDENED
AT THESE. EVENTS.
OUR OUR CEO HAS SAID IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE TEN BAY ANTS
ACCIDENT WE ARE DOING A TOP TO
BOTTOM REVIEW.
OF OUR PROGRAM.
THAT REVIEW IS ONGOING.
BUT WE BELIEVE SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER
AND WILL SAVE LIVES AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING THEM A SAFE
AS POSSIBLE.
WE WILL DEVELOP TEST AND DEPLOY
THIS TECHNOLOGY WILL CONTINUE TO
REVIEW AND IMPROVE IT TO ENSURE
RIGOROUS SAFETY INSURANCES ARE
IN PLACE.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE FUTURE
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANDREW'S MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO SELF DRIVING
TECHNOLOGY.
THESE VEHICLES OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE SAFETY AND
EFFICIENCY OF THE PASSENGERS
AND GOODS TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
AND WE TRULY BELIEVE WILL
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR MANY
PEOPLE.
WHO HAS COMMITTED TO CALIFORNIA
OUR HOME IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH STATE
LAWMAKERS REGULATORS ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS AND CITIES TO SAFELY
IN A GREAT SELF DRIVING VEHICLES
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SO?
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IT PART IN TODAY'S
HEARING I LOOK FOR TO ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RON ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN FRAZIER.
I'M MY NAME'S RON MEDFORD AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR SAFETY FOR
WINDOW FORMALLY THE GOOGLE SELF
DRIVING CAR PROJECT.
AND WE'RE PROBABLY BASED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEIR
HEADQUARTERS IN MOUNTAIN VIEW.
MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL OFFICES IN
SAN FRANCISCO IN A NINETY ONE
ACRE TESTING FACILITY AT THE
FORMER CASTLE AIRFORCE BASE THAT
MERCED COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO WRITE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF WHERE FULLY SELF DRIVING
TECHNOLOGY STANDS CURRENTLY.
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY REMINDING
EVERYONE OF THE POTENTIAL THAT
FULLY SELF DRIVING CARS HAVE ON
REDUCING THE GROWING NUMBER OF
FATALITIES. THEIR CAR ON OUR
NATION'S ROADS.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LATEST YEAR OF COMPLETE DATA
SHOWS THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE PEOPLE. DIED
IN TRAFFIC CRASHES.
THIS IS MORE THAN A FIVE POINT
SIX PERCENT INCREASE OVER TWENTY
FIFTEEN.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY
SIXTEEN SAW SEVEN PERCENT
INCREASE IN TRAFFIC DEATHS
COMPARED TO TWENTY FIFTEEN.
RESULTED NEARLY THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED DEATHS THAT YEAR.
ONLY THE STATE OF TEXAS HAD MORE
TRAFFIC DESTINED CALIFORNIA.
CLEARLY THE NUMBERS ARE GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THIS IS IN SPITE OF THE FACT
THAT THE AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY
TODAY'S MANUFACTURING THE SAFEST
CARS EVER BUILT IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE. TO HELP
DRIVERS PREVENT CRASHES
AS WELL AS A DOCUMENT CRASH
PROTECTION BUILT INTO EVERY CAR
TODAY.
BUT EVEN WITH THE MOST ADVANCED
SAFETY MEASURES TODAY THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES AT NINE
FOUR PERCENT. OF ALL VEHICLE
CRASHES ARE DUE TO HUMAN ERROR.
THESE ERRORS RELATE TO
DISTRACTION DROWSY DRIVING.
DRIVING WHILE UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL AND DRUGS
MISJUDGING GAPS AT INTERSECTIONS
EXCESSIVE SPEEDS LIST GOES ON
AND ON AND ON.
FULLY SELF DRIVING CARS HAVE THE
LIFESAVING POTENTIAL TO
ELIMINATE MUCH OF THE HUMAN
THEIR THAT LED TO THE SIX POINT
THREE MILLION POLICE REPORTED
CRASHES LAST YEAR IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE BEGIN DEVELOPING AND TESTING
AUTONOMOUS CARS ON PUBLIC ROADS
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
APPROXIMATE NINE YEARS AGO.
AND WE HAVE BEEN DRIVEN AND
WE'VE DRIVEN MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION TARA SMILE SINCE WE
STARTED.
WE'RE PLEASED THAT CALIFORNIA
DMV HAS COMPLETED ITS TESTING AN
OPERATING REGULATIONS.
NOW THERE'S REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT ALLOWS
FOR DRIVERLESS TESTING AND
DEPLOYMENT. OF FULLY SELF
DRIVING CARS.
AS WE RECENTLY ANNOUNCED WAY MO
HAS APPLIED TO THE DMV TO
CONDUCT DRIVERLESS TESTING IN
CALIFORNIA AND OUR APPLICATIONS
CURRENTLY PENDING.
WE'VE ALSO SUBMITTED TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION A
PROPOSAL FOR PAID DEPLOYMENT
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT ALIGN WITH
THE DMV'S DEPLOYMENT REGULATIONS.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE WAY WILL HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT WE INTEND TO
PROVIDE DRIVERLESS TASKER
TRANSPORTATION THE SERVICE TO
THE PUBLIC IN THE METRO PHOENIX
AREA AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES AND HAS RECENTLY BEGUN
ITS EFFORTS TO REVIVE BOTH AN
INTERIM AND A LONG TERM
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TO
INTEGRATE AB IS OUR SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES.
AS A ANOTHER PART FOR THE
COMMERCIAL TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK.
WHEN I WAS PARTICIPATING THIS
PROCESS BUT THE P. YOU SEE AS WE
ARE EAGER TO LAUNCH HERE IN OUR
HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST OCTOBER WE ENTERED A NEW
PHASE OF TESTING IN PHOENIX.
WITHIN THIS NEW PHASE WE ARE
RELYING ON OUR SAFEST AND MOST
ADVANCED FULLY SELF DRIVING CARS
TODAY BUILT ON THAT CHRYSLER
PACIFICA HYBRID PLATFORM.
WHERE TESTING JUST DRIVING
AUTONOMOUS?
AND AUTONOMOUS MODE WITHOUT A
TEST DRIVER.
BEHIND THE WHEEL.
THESE TRAVELED THROUGH THE.
THESE VEHICLES TRAVEL WITHIN A
DEFINED GEOGRAPHIC AREA IN THE
PHOENIX REGION WHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN TESTED EXTENSIVELY.
THESE VEHICLES WILL OPERATE
ALONGSIDE OUR TESTING FLEE THE.
WITH DRIVERS AND WILL CONTINUE.
IN IN THE PHOENIX AREA FOR.
SOME FORCE OF SIEBEL TIME. FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS WAY
THOSE EARLY RIDER PROGRAM ALSO
HAVE THE CHANCE TO ACCESS.
FULLY SELF DRIVING CARS THESE
RIDERS WILL THEN. FOR THE FIRST
TIME HAVE THE ACCESS TO.
DRIVE OUR CARS ARE NOT DRIVEN
BY HUMANS.
EVENTUALLY THIS AREA WILL GROW
OVER TIME COVER OTHER LOCATIONS
AS WELL.
ARE FULLY SELF DRIVING SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO SAFELY OPERATE
WITHOUT HUMAN DRIVER AND WE HAVE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED KEY
FEATURES FOR THIS LEVEL AUTONOMY.
OUTSIDE EL SELF DRIVING MINIVANS
REQUEST WAS SWEETER SENSORS
CAMERAS RADARS AND LASERS.
THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT ENTIRELY IN
HOUSE AND SPECIFICALLY FOR FULLY
AUTONOMOUS DRIVING.
WITH THESE SENSORS ARE CARS CAN
SEE SIGNIFICANT FARTHER AND MORE
ACTUALLY THAN A HUMAN CAN.
FOR EXAMPLE OUR SENSORS ARE SO
POWERFUL THAT THEY CAN SEE UP TO
THREE HUNDRED METERS AWAY. THE
LIKE OF NEARLY THIRTY.
THREE FOOTBALL FIELDS.
OF SELF DRIVE A MINI VANS RUN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HEALTH
CHECKS EVERY SECOND AND ARE
EQUIPPED WITH UNIQUE LEVEL FOR
SAFETY FEATURES.
SUCH AS BACKUP STEERING. BRAKING
POWER AND COMPUTING.
IF ANY ISSUE IS DETECTED ON THE
ROAD THESE REDUNDANT SYSTEMS.
CAN HELP OUR VEHICLE GET TO A
DESTINATION SAFELY ARE BRING THE
VEHICLE TO A SAFE STOP IF
REQUIRED.
AS A CALIFORNIA COMPANY WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT EXPANDING
OPERATIONS HERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH STATE
REGULATORS LIKE THE DMV IN THE
P. YOU SEE. TO BRING THE PROMISE
OF A TAKE AB TECHNOLOGY SAFELY.
SAFETY AND SAFETY AND MOBILITY
CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF WHEN I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF AND
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY. I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THE AND THAT I THINK WE
HANDED OUT.
FIRST EVER.
.
PUBLICATIONS THAT WE DID TO TRY
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY HOW IT WORKS.
AND THE SAFETY STEPS THAT WE
TAKE TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
AS WE DEVELOP AND DEPLOY THE
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU RUN MOVED FULL.
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M PAUL HAMMERS
BOSS CHIEF COUNSEL AND POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR TRANSPORTATION IS A
SERVICE FOR GENERAL MOTORS.
THANKS FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES AND GM AND CREWS
AUTOMATION'S PROGRAM FOR
DEVELOPING MANUFACTURING TESTING
AND DEPLOYING THEM.
GM IS DRIVEN BY OUR GOAL FOR A
FUTURE WITH ZERO CRASHES ZERO
EMISSIONS AND ZERO CONGESTION.
DEVELOPING AND DEPLOYING SELF
DRIVING VEHICLES DESIGNED TO
SERVE ALL THREE ELEMENTS OF THAT
VISION.
SAFETY IS OUR TOP PRIORITY.
IT'S ALSO THE DRIVING MOTIVATION
BEHIND SELF DRIVING VEHICLES
EFFORTS.
NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE
KILLED EACH YEAR IN THE UNITED
STATES ROADS.
THAT SHOULD BE SHOCKING.
TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF A SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN AIRPLANE CRASHING AND
KILLING EVERYONE ON BOARD. EVERY
WEEK.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA MOTOR VEHICLE
FATALITIES TOTAL THREE THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
NHTSA ESTIMATES THAT NINETY FOUR
PERCENT OF VEHICLE CRASHES ARE
THE RESULT OF HUMAN ERROR OR
BEHAVIOR.
THIS MEANS THAT IF WE CAN REDUCE
HUMAN ERROR WE CAN REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLE CRASHES AND
FATALITIES.
THIS IS THE GREAT PROMISE OF
SELF DRIVE VEHICLES
BY ELIMINATING THE HUMAN DRIVER
ENHANCE HUMAN ERROR. WE CAN HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR ROADS.
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES WON'T GET
DISTRACTED.
THEY WON'T DRIVE DRUNK.
AND THEY WON'T SPEED OR ENGAGE
IN OTHER RISKY BEHAVIORS.
THE SAME TIME.
WINTER STAND THAT IN ORDER TO
GAIN THE PUBLIC'S TRUST IN OUR
TECHNOLOGY WE MUST SHOW THAT WE
CAN SAFELY AND RELIABLY. DELIVER
THEM TO THEIR DESIRED
DESTINATIONS
THAT'S Y. WE PUBLISHED OUR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SELF DRIVING
SAFETY REPORT IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR.
THIS REPORT DESCRIBES IN LAYMAN
TERMS.
HOW WE CONSTRUCTED DRIVE SELF
DRIVING VEHICLE FROM THE GROUND
UP?
SAFETY IS OUR FOREMOST
CONSIDERATION.
THE REPORT DESCRIBES GM'S
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE SAFETY
LEVERAGING MORE THAN A CENTURY
OF EXPERIENCE AND SAFELY
DESIGNING MANUFACTURING AND
DEPLOYING VEHICLES.
THE REPORT ALSO ADDRESSES ITS IS
VOLUNTARY SAFETY SELF ASSESSMENT
PROCESS OUTLINED IN ITS GUIDANCE
VISION FOR SAFETY EIGHTY S. TO
POINT OUT.
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES EACH OF
THE TWELVE SAFETY ELEMENTS THAT
THE AGENCY ADVISE COMPANIES TO
CONSIDER. WHEN DEVELOPING
AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGIES.
I THINK.
AS AS WAY MODE DID WE.
DISTRIBUTED A COPY OF THE GM
REPORT I THINK.
WE IN. GM AND WAY MORE THE ONLY
TWO OF UP PUT THAT OUT SO FAR.
THE REPORT.
GM IS ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT
IT'S PART OF OUR VISION FOR THE
FUTURE WE BELIEVE THAT ALL SELF
DRIVING VEHICLES SHOULD BE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
IN FACT.
GM PLANS TO INTRODUCE TWENTY NEW
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE.
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES ARE A GOOD
WAY TO DEPLOY ELECTRIFICATION AT
SCALE.
OUR SELF DRIVING VEHICLES TODAY
ARE BUILT ON THE BOLT EVEY
PLATFORM OUR AWARD WINNING
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT CAN TRAVEL
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILES
ON A SINGLE CHARGE.
THE BOLT HAS NO TAILPIPE
EMISSIONS WHICH ADVANCES OUR
GOAL OF ZERO EMISSIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT ELECTRIC VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD BE THE
FOUNDATION FOR SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES AND CAR SHARING.
AND A STARTING POINT TOWARD THE
WORLD ZERO CRASHES ZERO
EMISSIONS IN ZERO CONGESTION
THAT WE SEEK.
SPEAKING OF CONGESTION.
IT'S AN INCREASING CONCERN
ESPECIALLY IN THE URBAN CENTERS.
GM BELIEVES ITSELF DRIVING AND
ELECTRIC PROPULSION TECHNOLOGY
CAN ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH CONGESTION.
OUR PLAN IS TO DEPLOY OUR SELF
DRIVING VEHICLES IN FLEETS
THAT ARE OWNED BY GM NOT TO SELL
THEM TO INDIVIDUALS.
THAT WAY WE CAN ASSURE.
THAT THEY ARE PROPERLY
MAINTAINED AND UPDATED.
IN ADDITION BY WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE WILL
OPERATE WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
PROVIDE MOBILITY SOLUTIONS TO A
GREATER NUMBER OF PEOPLE. AND AT
THE SAME TIME REDUCE CONGESTION.
SERVICES THE GM SWEETS MAY
PROVIDE INCLUDE RIDE SHARING IT
FIRST MILE LAST MILE SUPPLEMENTS
TO PUBLIC TRANSIT.
GM HAS DESIGNED AND BUILT SELF
DRIVING VEHICLE FROM THE GROUND
UP WITH SAFETY IS OUR TOP
PRIORITY. OUR VEHICLES CURRENTLY
IN ITS THIRD GENERATION IS THE
ONLY SELF DRIVING VEHICLE THAT
IS BEING MASS PRODUCED IN AN
AUTOMOBILE PRODUCTION FACILITIES.
THESE VEHICLES ARE CURRENTLY
BEING MADE AT OUR ASSEMBLY PLANT
IN LAKE ORIA IN MICHIGAN.
WE CAN ACHIEVE OUR SAFETY
COMMITMENT BY INTEGRATING SAFETY
INTO THE SYSTEM TO THE VEHICLE
AND BY CONFIGURING MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF REDUNDANCY INTO EACH
CRITICAL SAFETY SYSTEM.
THIS PROCESS IS EXPLAINED AGAIN
IN OUR SAFETY REPORT.
MORE DETAILS.
TODAY. EACH VEHICLE IN EACH
VEHICLE WHERE TESTING WE HAVE
TWO AUTOMATED VEHICLE TRAINERS
ARE WHAT WE CALL AB TEASE
ONE PERSON WHO SITS IN THE
DRIVER SEAT TO CONSTANTLY
MONITOR THE ROAD IN VEHICLE
NAVIGATION.
AND ANOTHER TO MAKE THEM AND
RECORD OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE
VEHICLE'S PERFORMANCE.
WE TRAIN OUR AB TEAS AND SAFE
OPERATION OF VEHICLES IN REQUIRE
BACKGROUND CHECKS
AB TEAS ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE
TRAINING IN THE CLASSROOM AND I
CLOSE COURSES BEFORE THEY CAN
OPERATE A CAR IN PUBLIC ROADS.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED REQUIREMENTS
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
AND AB T. CAN BE ON THE ROAD.
THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO
UNDERGO CONTINUING TRAINING
AFTER THEY HAVE BEGUN TO TEST
OUR VEHICLES ON PUBLIC ROADS.
WE MADE A CONSCIOUS DECISION TO
TEST IN THE MOST CHALLENGING
COMPLICATED ENVIRONMENT
AVAILABLE DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO.
FROM PEDESTRIANS AND CYCLISTS A
TROLLEY CARS AND FOOD TRUCKS
EVEN. JAY WALKING OR COONS.
HER HILLY SAN FRANCISCO
ENVIRONMENT EXPOSES OUR VEHICLES
TO ENDLESS CHALLENGES
AND ENABLING THEM TO LEARN AND
IMPROVE AT A RAPID PACE.
TESTING ITS ABSENCE GO HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY ACCELERATED OUR
PROGRESS TO THE POINT THAT LATE
LAST YEAR WE ANNOUNCED THAT WE
EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY
FULLY SELF DRIVING VEHICLES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN.
WHILE WE BELIEVE THIS GOAL IS
ACHIEVABLE. OUR PROGRESS WILL
ALWAYS BE GATED BY SAFETY.
AS WE HAVE DONE SINCE OUR AB
PROGRAM'S INCEPTION WILL NOT
TAKE ANY STEPS.
UNTIL WE ARE HIGHLY CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN DO IT SAFELY.
PROTECTING THE SAFETY OF OUR
CUSTOMERS AND THOSE SHARING THE
ROADS OF THEIR VEHICLES IS OUR
HIGHEST CONCERN AND PRIORITY.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR PROVIDING GM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
THOUGHTS AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU THIS REVIEW HAVE A
QUESTIONS OF THE LECTURES SURE
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING.
NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF WHAT YOU
HAD TO SAY.
BUT JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY ANY I THINK SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS WERE RAISED
BY SOME OF THE PREVIOUS PANELS
ARE NOT FORGIVE ME IF YOU'VE
ALREADY ADDRESS THEM BUT. ME HOW
ARE YOU.
APPROACHING THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW PRIVACY CONCERNS OR THE
HACK ABILITY.
AT SOME OF THE OTHER CONCERNS
THAT WOULD BE A BALD TIRES
WHATEVER THAT WHATEVER THE
COMMENT YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE.
IT TURNS ARE HOW ARE YOU
ADDRESSING THESE AS YOU AS YOU
TESTS.
YOUR TECHNOLOGY.
OUR I CAN GO FIRST.
ONE THING I WILL SAY IS THAT ON
THE MAINTENANCE OR SAFETY OF THE
OF THE VEHICLES THEMSELVES I
MEAN WE WE'VE SAID THAT.
RIGHT NOW ARE OUR BUSINESS PLAN
IS FOR.
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES APARTMENT CAPTURED
FLEET SO WE.
OWN AND MAINTAIN THOSE VEHICLES
OURSELVES AND SO PROVIDING
SERVICE AND ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE SAFE.
FROM THE NEEDED MAINTENANCE IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL AND FOR THE
FIRST FOR A STABLE FUTURE BE
DOING OURSELVES.
I THINK THAT.
ON THE CYBER ON THE CYBER SIDE
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AS WAS
MENTIONED IT'S AND IT'S A
CONSTANT ONGOING PROCESS YOU
DON'T SOLVE IT IN A DAY YOU WORK
ON IT EVERYDAY AND SO. THIS IS A
PROCESS THAT WE.
TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE YOU
KNOW USE A LOTS OF.
HELP AND AND GOOGLE AS PART OF
THAT HELP BUT MORE THAN THAT.
.
UNDERSTANDING THE VERBAL
ABILITIES IN ADDRESSING THEM
WERE PART OF THE OUT OF ICE ACT.
IN AND.
AND THERE'S A PROCESS BY
SHARING INFORMATION THAT. ON A
SUICIDE REISSUE SO THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE DO.
I JUST ADD ON TO THAT WHAT I WE
HAVE A A SIMILAR POTION ETHOS.
I THINK OUT WITH REGARDS TO. A
CYBER THAT THIS IS ACTION ISSUE
THAT THE AUTOMOBILE INDUSTRY
MORE GENERALLY HAS TO GRAPPLE
WITH THAT AND EXPENSE TO
CONNECTED CARS AS WELL AND SO. I
THINK ADAM. WHAT OUR APPROACH TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IS IT IT
NEED NOT BE SORT OF CONNECTED
INTO THIS THE ITS SYSTEM?
AND SO.
ROUTE REDUCING THE THE THREAT
FACTORS I AS PART OF OUR THING
UP BUILDING AT AND THEN ON
PRIVACY.
I THINK WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
THINKING ABOUT.
CONSUMER PRIVACY ISSUES GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE BEEN RUNNING A
FLEET OF.
.
HAVING THESE RIGHTS ARE
PASSENGERS FOR MANY YEARS.
SO WE THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST
THEIR PRIVACY AND WE WE HAVE A
PRIVACY.
DESIGN TEAM WHO IS THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO MAXIMIZE ALL OF
THIS IN IN THE AV WORLD AND WILL
BE HAVING MORE SENSORS ON THE.
VEHICLE.
I WANTED TO ADDRESS ONE THING IT
DID THERE ARE SEVERAL OF THE
WITNESSES SEEM TO.
PROCEED FROM THE PREMISE THAT.
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES MUST BE
PERFECT OR NEAR PERFECT.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THESE
VEHICLES OF THE STANDARD SHOULD
BE. DO THESE VEHICLE SAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF LIVES.
BECAUSE WE WE ARE LOSING THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND WATER SIXTY ONE
LIVES.
TWO YEARS AGO WAS MOST RECENT
STATS.
AND THE QUESTION SHOULDN'T BE
OUR IS IT BECAUSE IT.
.
STOPPING YOUR IN EVERY SINGLE
SITUATION ARE ARE THEY NOT
CRASHING OR IN EVERY SINGLE
SITUATION DO THEY PREVENT. A
CRASH FOR ONE THING IT WILL BE
THIRTY YEARS BEFORE. AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ARE THE ENTIRE CAR
PARKED ON THE ROAD. I FOR A LONG
TIME THEY WILL BE SHARING THE
ROAD WITH.
HUMAN DRIVERS AND MAYBE LONGER
THAN THIRTY YEARS.
BUT AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS SO SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S SORT OF A.
IN MY VIEW AND GM'S VIEW OF
MISTAKEN FRAMING OF THE ISSUE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE HOW CLOSE TO
PERFECTION ARE WE IT SHOULD BE.
ARE ARE WE SAVING A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF HUMAN LIVES
ANOTHER THING ON ON CYBER.
THAT WHEN THE PEOPLE TIME
OUTSIDE WHAT WE DID AT OUR
SUBSIDIARY CREWS AUTOMATION IS
WE WENT OUT AND HIRED THE TO
DEEP PACKERS.
AND WE HAVE THEM DOT DOINGS ARE
RED TEAM EVALUATION OF OUR.
OUR TECHNOLOGY.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
IT IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY HE'S
SABERS IS A BIG CHALLENGE AND I
THINK MOST COMPANIES MOST AUTO
COMPANIES AND MY FELLOW
PANELISTS OF THEIR COMPANIES ARE
VERY AWARE OF IT AND WORKING
HARD ON IT BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO BE.
FOREVER VIGILANT ON.
SO IT AND AND THEN I THINK THAT
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO
MENTION. WAS.
THE INSURANCE IN THIS IS THIS IS
A WHOLE KIND OF.
SERIES OF CONSOLATION ISSUES BUT.
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE IN
GENERAL ARE OUR ECONOMIC ACT
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE AND THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ENTITLED TO PRIVATE
INFORMATION ANY MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE IS MEAN THAT'S NOT HOW THEY
DO IT NOW AND IF THEY WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THAT. INSURANCE
TRANSACTION WITH WITH AN AUTO
COMPANY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THEY CAN ASK THE COMPANY IF
THEY CAN HAVE DATA AND THE
COMPANY CAN CHOOSE TO PROVIDE IT
OR NOT.
BUT BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE ANY SORT OF.
.
PRESUMPTION THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO. ADDITIONAL DATA.
MERELY BECAUSE OF THEIR
INSURERS.
THANKS.
YEAH I APPRECIATE THE THE
ANSWERS IT YEAH YOU KNOW JUST
COME.
MACRO COMMENTS I'VE IT WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
MAY I I THINK I SAID I CAN
RIVERS ON THE COLLEGES HAD HER.
BEFORE I LEFT HERE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO
BE READY BEFORE SOCIETY IS.
I FOR ONE AM A BIG BELIEVER IN
THE BENEFITS OF ECONOMIST
TECHNOLOGY WHETHER IT'S THE
SAFETY COMPONENT WHETHER IT'S
HOW WE TOTALLY. CHANGE.
ARE BUILT LANDSCAPE OF OF
CITIES AND AND HOW MOBILITY AND
HOW WE GET AROUND ALISON YOU CAN
YOU CAN.
THAT LEAST SO I POSITED FOUR
YEARS AGO IN THIS TEXT TALK
TURNED. PARKING GARAGES AND.
INTO AN APARTMENT BUILDINGS ARE
PARKS OR OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE
A MASSIVE IMPACT BUT IT'S
COMPLICATED.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO HAVE WITH
EVERYBODY WHO SPOKEN TODAY.
AND AND YEAH I'M THAT'S OUR JOB
TO BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND
AND HASH OUT THOSE HARD
CONVERSATIONS.
AND HOPEFULLY PUT FORTH A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT.
BOTH PROMOTES.
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION AND
BUT IS ALSO SAFE.
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
THE DIFFICULT BALANCE THAT WILL
HAVE MOVING FORWARD BUT
APPRECIATE ALL AND EVERYONE
ELSE'S COME TO SPEAK TODAY. ON
LOOKING FOR MORE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SO.
THIS IS KIND OF A GENERAL FOR
ALL OF YOU QUESTION FOR ALL OF
YOU.
SO WHAT IF ANY.
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES DO WE.
AS CAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT WE MAKE
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE. OF
AUTOMATED VEHICLES ON THE ROAD.
A WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCES OF.
URBAN RURAL. AND.
ESERVER SUGGESTED.
MODIFICATIONS THAT WE COULD BE
MAKING TO CALTRANS
TO. MAKE THIS INTEGRATION BETTER.
I WAS LAST NIGHT OF THE FIRST
TIMES OF THE FIRST THIS TIME.
.
I THINK THAT FOR THE MOST PART A
LOT OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CHANGES THAT CITIES THINK ABOUT.
ARE FOR VEHICLE TO VEHICLE.
YOU KNOW IT OR VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT KIND OF
RADIO WAVE COMMUNICATION.
FOR OUR VEHICLE WE WE DON'T USE
THAT KIND OF COMMUNICATION SO WE
WOULDN'T NEED THAT.
WHAT WE ARE INTERESTED IN IS
MORE?
?
ELECTRICAL. INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT'S THAT INVOLVES A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PLAYERS AND A LOT
OF DIFFERENT INTERESTS AND SO
FORTH AND SO IT'S. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IT'S VALUABLE IN
AND WORTH WHILE TO START
THINKING ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THAT.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU WANT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON A
CALIFORNIA IS IS HAS.
A POLICY OF ENCOURAGING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
YOU'VE GOT HAVE CHARGES FOR
THEM TO.
FOR THEM TO BE A VIABLE METHOD
OF OF MOST PEOPLE GETTING AROUND
SO THAT THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST.
THE OTHERS.
I TO OTHERS THAT HAD.
SORT OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE POLICY MORE
BROADLY I THINK IN IT'S CRITICAL
TO INTEGRATE. INTO PUBLIC
TRANSIT AS WELL AS TO GENERAL.
RIDESHARE TO START TO MAKE THE
SHIFT AWAY FROM PARKING SPOTS
ENABLE MORE A PICK UP AND DROP
OFF LOCATIONS.
AND THAT SORT OF CAN.
YEAH I GO TO THE VISION A YOU
DISCUSS THINGS I THINK THAT WILL
TAKE A LOT OF WORK.
AND WILL UNLOCK A LOT OF VALUE.
A AND I THINK THE OTHER IS.
AS DISCUSSED EARLIER IN PANELS
THERE IS A RISK OF AS THE AV'S
BECOME READILY MORE ACCESSIBLE
WHICH IS GREAT TO INCREASE
MOBILITY ACCESS THERE WILL BE. A
HIGHER DEMAND AND SO THERE MAY
RUN THE RISK OF CONGESTION SO
UNLOCKING THE ABILITY TO.
USE.
POLICIES SUCH AS CONGESTION
PRICING OR ENCOURAGE HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANES ARE
OTHER WAYS TO ENCOURAGE AT THESE
AV'S P. SHARED. A AND POOLS I
THINK WOULD BE CRITICAL FOR
THEIR SUCCESSFUL DEPLOYMENT.
WELL I I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THE THE PARKING ISSUE WHERE
THE THE PICK UP POINT ISSUE AND
DROP OFF POINT ISSUE FOR.
FOR PASSENGERS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE AND I THINK YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
I'M SURE YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF US
BUT WORKING WITH.
IT'S THE CITIES AND LIKE IN THE
SMALL AREAS AND.
PHOENIX WERE ATTESTING TO AND
THAT THE CITY SEEM TO BE VERY
INTERESTED IN HELPING US FIND
LOCATIONS ANYWHERE WHICH WE CAN.
DO A SAFETY DROP OFF AND PICK
UPS WITHOUT INTERFERING WITH
TRAFFIC SOME MORE EMPHASIS ON ON
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT AYE
I THINK FIXING POTHOLES THIS IS
GOOD FOR OUR CUSTOMER SITE MOVIE.
BIG GRAVE WE CAN JUST FIX MORE
THE BOTTLES I THINK.
HAS BEEN HAS BE ONE ON YOUR ON
YOUR SERVICE. IT AT YOUR SERVICE.
NOW.
COMING NEAR YOU.
NO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY AND WHEN
YOU MENTION THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
GOING FORWARD SO ARE WE LIMITING.
TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS
CONCENTRATION.
ON.
THIS VERY CONCENTRIC ISSUE AND
SO DO I HAVE TO BUY A SEPARATE
CAR.
TO GO OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WANT
TO GO TO TEXAS
OR IF I WANNA GO TO WYOMING
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT MOVING IN
THIS DIRECTION. AND SO SAY I I
COMMIT TO.
THE.
.
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND ALSO I GO TO THE BORDER AND
I DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
INFASTRUCTURE.
UP BECAUSE IT THERE'D NOT
CONCENTRATING ON LIKE WE SHOULD.
I THINK THAT.
.
ONE OF THINGS THAT RAISES IS
QUESTION OF OF.
UNIFORM FEDERAL POLICY VERSES A.
STATE BY STATE POLICY
AND.
SOME OF THE FOLKS HERE WERE
WERE ENCOURAGING YOU TO SOME OF
THE EARLIER PANELS WE'RE
ENCOURAGING YOU TO.
AND ACT.
LAWS GOVERNING THE PHYSICAL CAR.
ARE AS A STATE AND A STATE BY
STATE BASIS.
IF WE DO THAT I THINK WILL END
UP WITH THE SCENARIO THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE NEVADA MAY
HAVE A DIFFERENT ONE MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT ONE FROM OREGON AND
AND. YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA THIRD
AND SO FORTH.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE FEATURES OF
THAT.
THE LEGISLATION THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION IS THAT IT KEEPS IN
PLACE THE CURRENT ALLOCATION OF
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENTS.
AND IT IT THE THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE UNIFORM.
ARE THIS RESPONSIBILITY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT THE
LOCAL.
.
MORE LOCAL AND STATE CONCERNS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE'S
SO SO THAT'S I I THINK IMPORTANT.
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT JUST
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT.
YOU OVER FREIGHT.
OH WE LOOK AT RIGHT NOW OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ARE. CONSISTENTLY IMPACTED
BY THE DIESEL DISOWNS IN AND WE
LOOK FOR A AN ABILITY TO GO TO
ELECTRIFICATION ON FREIGHT. ON
VEHICLES.
.
UNLESSWE REDUCE THIS CONGESTION
OUTSIDE OF OUR PORTS
LET'S WE MAKE A CONCENTRATED
EFFORT.
HAVE THINGS IT CAN BE THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY BUT SITTING NOT
MAKING ANY KIND OF.
MONEY OR TURNS OR. IS JUST
SITTING IS CONGESTION IN YOU'D
MENTION ABOUT TO FROM MODES OF
TRYING TO REDUCE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF
CONTRAFLOW AND GETTING CAPACITY
OF IN DIRECTIONAL TRAFFIC.
A BIT.
I WANTED WE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED.
WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
ABILITY TO REDUCE CONGESTION OUT
OF OUR PORTS.
TO BE ABLE TO TO INCENTIVIZE AN
ECONOMY NUMBER ONE BECAUSE AGAIN
IT'S A THIRD OF OUR ECONOMY. IN
CALIFORNIA WE JUST MOVED UP TO
THE.
NUMBER FIVE IN THE WORLD.
BUT I THINK WHAT WHEN YOU GUYS
TALK ABOUT YOUR ABILITY TO.
BE PART OF THIS PROCESS I THINK
IT'S A TWO WAY STREET WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT WANTING TO BE PART IN
THE FREIGHT INDUSTRY. AND. IN
THE TIMES WORLD.
WE HAVE TO BECAUSE THE
INTEGRATION WITH.
NANA THOMAS AND THOMAS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE.
THE CONUNDRUM IF WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THE
REDUCTION OF CONGESTION AND
IMPROVE THAT ECONOMY BECAUSE OUR
FREIGHT IS GOING TO INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY. IN THE NEXT THREE
TO FIVE YEARS
WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE THAT
INDUSTRY ANY REASON TO GO
ELSEWHERE.
SO I THINK THAT.
NOT ONLY IS THE STATE HAVE TO BE
A PART OF IT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCE BOARD HAS BEEN PART OF
THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY ALSO HAS TO
BE PART OF THAT. THREE LEGGED
STOOL.
CREATE AND SUPPORTER ECONOMY.
NOT ONLY TO ADVANCE IN
TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO REDUCTION OF
GHGS PARTICULATES.
BUT IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF
ECONOMY PEOPLE MAKING. A LIVING.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOU AND YOUR INDUSTRY BEING PART
OF THAT.
THE PROCESS GOING FORWARD.
I THINK IT HAS COMMENTS AND I
VERY MUCH AGREE I THINK THE A
THREE LEGGED STOOL APPROACHES
CRITICAL.
WE WOULD BE EAGER TO CONTINUE
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND THEN
LOOKING AT BACK TO
INFRASTRUCTURE GHG. AYE IF WE
THINK ABOUT SORT OF WHAT THE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE I WILL MEAN
FOR THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY IT
WILL ALLOW LONG HAUL TRUCKING.
WITH AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BUT
THEN.
THAT WILL.
WHAT WE'RE CALLING CREATE A LOT
OF TRANSFER HUBS WHICH WILL BE A
LOT OF SHORT STOPS
AND THAT WILL BE DRIVEN BY HUMAN
DRIVERS BUT ONE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT?
IS THAT FOR SHORTER HAUL
TRUCKING THERE'S ABILITY TO RELY
MORE ON THE ELECTRIC DRIVE TRAIN
RATHER THAN.
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE FOR
SHORTER DISTANCES I THINK I CAN
HELP WITH SOME OF THE GHC AND
THAT IS ALSO BEEN LINKED BACK TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THESE TRANSFER
HUBS JUST OUT OF SIGHT. MAJOR
CITIES THAT WAS WOULD HELP WITH
THIS FLOW.
APPRECIATE IT SO I THINK THE
OUTCOME REALLY IS THE LOOKING
HOW THE ELECTRIFICATION GOING
TOWARDS. AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ARE
HYBRIDS OR WHATEVER THE THE
COMPONENT IS THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE. NEED TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF THE THE IMPACT OF
NOT BEING A PART OF THE.
THE BIG PICTURE OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE PLUGINS ARE READILY
ACCESSIBLE TO TOOK AT AND. FOR
THE MOBILITY OF THIS THIS
TECHNOLOGY YOU LOOK AT DIFFERENT
CASE SCENARIOS WHERE.
.
WHEN YOU DO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE THE PICK UP AND PICK
UP AREAS.
THE FAST CHARGING THAT WOULD BE
IMPERATIVE.
HARD TO HAVE THAT THERE SO. YOU
KNOW YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
WITH YOUR POLITICAL WILL IN YOUR
AND YOUR EXPERTISE.
WHERE WE HAVE THE LEGISLATURE?
CAN INTRODUCE ON WORK WITH OUR
AGENCIES IT AND MAKE IT A
PRIORITY. ANOTHER WAS AB EIGHT
WAS CLOSE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
BUT IT HAS BEEN SO I WOULD SAY.
A LEARNING PROCESS.
OKAY I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE PRIVATE INDUSTRY
DRIVE THIS NO PUN INTENDED BUS.
AND GET THIS THING GOING AND GET
GRAY BUREAUCRACY OUT OF THE WAY.
AND LET THE PRIVATE IS THREE
TAKE IT OVER GET IT DONE SO THAT
WE CAN PROMOTE AND GO OUT AND DO
THIS GOOD STUFF. THAT WE WANT TO
DO FOR THE ENVIRONMENT INFO. AND
AND SAVE SAVING LIVES.
SO I CAN THINK US ENOUGH AND
AGAIN. WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE OR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS HOW WE CAN BETTER
LEGISLATE. TO ADVOCATE.
ON THE OTHER PROCESS THAT NEWS
IS SO.
THAT'D THROUGH THE PROPONENTS
AND OPPONENTS.
I THINK USES SOCIAL WE WERE FOR
ON THIS I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
ENTERTAIN PUBLIC COMMENTS SO ANY
BUT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD TO
THE MIKE.
PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME.
WHO YOU REPRESENTING OF GIVE YOU
A COUPLE THREE MINUTES TO US?
STATE YOUR CASE.
WHILE ALL THIS.
MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PILOT
CHEAT ON BEHALF OF TESLA.
IN LIEU THE LATE HOUR.
WE JUST LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
APPRECIATE OF THE COMMON OF THE
COMMITTEES ENGAGEMENT ON THESE
ISSUES AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IN
ADVANCING OUR SHARED GOAL OF
IMPROVE DRIVER SAFETY.
IS THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON.
ANY OF THE SUBJECT MATTER TODAY.
SEEING NONE.
I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE PANELISTS IN
THE PUBLIC FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING. ALSO WANT TO
THANK MAYES MICE MY COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR BEING PART OF THIS.
.
WELL THOUGHT OUT A DISCUSSION.
IT'S CLEAR THAT A MASSIVE
DISRUPTION TO THE WAY PEOPLE GET
AROUND IS COMING.
AUTOMATED DRIVING IF DONE
CORRECTLY WILL VASTLY IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND SAVE LIVES.
HOWEVER SAFETY.
NOT PROFIT SHOULD BE THE FOCUS.
THESE VEHICLES SHOULD NOT JUST
DISPLACE HUMAN DRIVERS THEY MUST
OPERATE BETTER THAN THEM.
AND WITH THAT I WILL.
ADJOURN THIS.
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND TRANSPORTATION.
RICHARD